18h53 environs directs sur brut pour un
nouveau facebook live on va parler
aujourd'hui avec david dufresne qui est
journaliste indépendant mais aussi
écrivain et qui depuis le début du
mouvement un des gilets jaunes le 17
novembre dernier documente sur ces
réseaux sociaux des violences policières
il récupère ces images les illustres
donc sur ces réseaux sociaux on va en
parler avec lui on va essayer d'élargir
un peu notre horizon en parlant
justement du maintien de l'ordre à la
française quelle conséquence on peut
tenir de ce qui s'est passé de ces
dernières semaines le fait qu'il eut des
plusieurs milliers blessées que ce soit
du côté des forces de l'ordre à des
manifestants est ce qu'on aurait pu
éviter cela on va en parler dans ce live
du flash-ball également ce sera au
programme qui est très contesté
actuellement et puis avec tous vos
questions dans les commentaires
alors je vais citer quelques sujets mais
il y en aura beaucoup d'autres en voilà
c'est un live et interactif on prend le
temps de parler on prend le temps
d'aller au fond des choses et on va
essayer de le faire aussi avec vous avec
vos commentaires vos questions vous
pouvez réagir à tout moment et puis bah
n'hésitez pas également à partager ce
direct avec vos amis qui souhaiterait
juste devraient être informés un peu
plus sur ce sujet on va essayer voilà
d'élargir un peu cette cette pensée dans
cette actualité chargée en ce moment
depuis le début du mouvement des gilet
jaune
je disais à l'instant david dufresne
déjà merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation d'être venu dans notre
rédaction
depuis le début du mouvement d'aidé
gilet jaune vous illustrez sur les
réseaux sociaux des cas de violences
policières
comment vous faites et qu'est ce que
vous retenez de tout cela depuis le plus
d'élus alors en fait j'ai j'ai un petit
décalage c'est à dire j'ai démarré en
faite début décembre
à la fois sidérée par certaines images
que je pouvais voir sidéré par à
l'époque le silence médiatique et j'ai
donc commencé sur mon fil twitter a mais
comme une bravade en fait à faire un
titre halo place beauvau place beauvau
c'est donc l'endroit où se situe le
ministère de l'intérieur
ces deux surnoms l'unissent à
l'intérieur place beauvau qui est en
face de l'elysée en fête à léo place
beauvau c'est pour un signalement numéro
un numéro de numéro 3 à chaque fois je
mettais une photo une vidéo et puis je
disais ça s'est passé là et c'était une
façon de dire qu'est ce que vous faites
que qu'est ce que la police fait et ce
qui m'autorise et une certaine manière à
les interpeller c'est donc d'abord
n'importe qui peut interpeller le
ministère c'est la moindre des choses
mais un deuxième chose c'est que moi
j'ai travaillé sur les questions de
maintien de l'ordre j'ai écrit un
bouquin j'ai réalisé un livre un film
pardon sur cette question là sur les
émeutes de 2005 suivi du cpe de 2006
j'ai longtemps travaillé
que ce soit à mediapart à libération où
en tant qu indépendant sur les questions
policière et de et de liberté collective
est en fait acte a pris acte samedi
après samedi où mon signalement qui
était au départ une bravade est devenu
en fait à presque je me suis retrouvé
dans la peau du lanceur d'alert de
manière bénévole c'est à dire que j'ai
pas de rédaction derrière moi j'ai pas
de jets pas de salaire ou quoi que ce
soit hélas aujourd'hui je croule sous
les souris cadeaux j'en suis à 311 cas
que je signale c 311 cas il ya là dedans
je dirais une centaine de blessures
graves et je dirais qu'il ya 150
blessures moins graves
et puis il ya ce que j'appelle des
manquements à la déontologie du maintien
de l'ordre parce qu'en fait le maintien
de l'ordre
ces deux s'il ya des questions mesure où
il fonda theron proche du format leader
bah vous puissiez voilà on a la chance
d'avoir du temps vous puisse expliquer
les choses donc c'est très bien
et puis moi dès qu'elle est question je
les prendrai là aussi sans parisien et
puis les miennes il ya justement cette
question sur laquelle j'aimerai sur
lesquels j'aimerais a bondi quant à
israël il dit à l'instant sur c'est ces
violences policières que vous reprenez
ces signalements
comment vous arrivez à les authentifier
a retrouvé les images comment parce que
5 sur les réseaux sociaux on a vu
énormément d'image un peu dans tous les
sens qui parfois ne sont pas toujours en
lien avec ce qui se passait comment on
arrive à authentifier une scène parce
que derrière c'est comme alors un très
très gros travail alors bye à 30 ans de
métier parce que j'ai quand même un
certain âge
j'essaie au minimum de situer là où ça a
été tourné et j'essaie au mieux de
contextualiser donc ben j'essaie de
retrouver la source
c'est quand je dis la source
c'est-à-dire la personne qui a filmé
j'essaie de voir s'il y a à côté des
issues des articles 6 dans les
commentaires en fait on sent assez
rapidement si les commentaires sont
sérieux si s'il ya du sérieux c'est à
dire voilà c'est un travail de pour le
coup de journalistes classique de de
recoupements et jusqu'ici je suis
absolument heureux je dois dire fier de
n'être tomber dans aucun piège de viège
où un fox qui a pu y avoir il ya
beaucoup de choses qui ont circulé des
choses qui sont d'ailleurs à mon avis
extrêmement dangereuse pour le mouvement
c'est à dire que si le mouvement devient
lui même vecteur de mauvaises
informations il se tire une balle dans
le pied
voilà mais moi je je je je fais pas
stricto sensu partie du mouvement je
suis passionné par ce mouvement et je
dis juste que évidemment faire attention
donc il ya par exemple plein de vidéos
qui ressortent des vidéos qui date de
2016 2017
il y à un mouvement manif ou un travail
etc on a pu parfois des vidéos qu'ils
ressentaient de ces voix là
ensuite il ya des interprétations qui
sont tout à fait erronée donc il faut
faire gaffe à tout ça et donc je je je
je je recoupe et je dois dire que ce qui
alors ça c'est la force des réseaux
sociaux c'est qu'en fait j'ai à dire une
petite dizaine de personnes qui passent
un temps fou et je les remercie je les
en remercie à me signaler des
signalements possible à regarder la
bouteille sur twitter mais pas plus que
ça parce que me tailler sur twitter
aujourd'hui malheureusement c'est je
croule c'est à dire samedi dernier
j'avais 7000 notification là dedans il y
avait évidemment simin notification qui
disait la même chose mais c'est trop
travail donc on parlera après comment
chômage bosse mais voilà il ya des gens
qui m'aident qui me qui m'alerte en me
disant tiens ça il faudrait aller voir
et c est justement il ya ces ya ces
signalements vous dites voilà un lot
place beau mais est ce qu'il ya un
retour justement de la place beauvau est
ce que depuis que vous avez commencé ce
travail vous avez un retour des
autorités du ministère de l'intérieur ou
de quelqu'un qui pourrait alors j'ai eu
aucun retour officiel ni même officieux
très sincèrement par contre ce que je
constate c'est que depuis trois jours
depuis 48 heures la question est
maintenant sur la place publique c'est à
dire que je me suis évertué à essayer
d'aller porter cette question là dans
des médias qui était susceptible de
toucher les politiques car là il ya une
cécité aussi à qui s'adresse des hommes
politiques on parlera de votre interview
avec castanet n'a essayé
de question d'avoir le retour justement
voilà c'est que oui mais est donc est
donc là depuis 48 heures on voit bien
qu'il y à un raidissement et un
affolement du politique sur ces
questions là c'est à dire que la
question aujourd'hui des violences
policières
elle fait la une des journaux télévisés
elle fait une double page dans le monde
elle demain ça fait la une de libération
c'est à dire que dans des médias qui
porte le débat on va dire voilà la
question est maintenant posée et ça
oblige le ministre de l'intérieur à
prendre des positions
donc j'ai l'impression que mes
signalement au bout d'un certain temps
où commençaient à porter leurs fruits et
puis après j'ai puisque j'ai bossé
beaucoup c'est vrai que question la
bâche et des flics qui m'appelle je fais
des anciens contacts crs et c'est qu'ils
me racontent qu'ils me font des
remontées du terrain
qu'est ce qu'ils en pensent parce que
c'est vrai qu'il ya une question
beaucoup de poser par exemple moi je le
vois dans mes direct sur le terrain
quand on couvre par exemple des
manifestations ou monde et gilet jaune
elle est très nombreux dans ceux qui
nous regardent à vous dire 20 a
interrogé des policiers va interroger
des crs oui malheureusement dans ses
dents quand ils sont en fonction peut
pas les intérêts en plus même en dehors
de leur travail il faudrait parfois
qu'il fasse à visage masqué réalité des
les sanctions alors cette question il
est intéressant de par les contacts que
vous pouvez avoir dans ses forces de
l'ordre la caisse qu'elle vous dise
alors autant que votre travail dit il et
il est clair que celle qui m'appelle
sont particulièrement républicaine parce
que moi je me place d'un point de vue
républicain c'est-à-dire jeudi que le
maintien de l'ordre doit obéir à des
règles
il a des règles et il doit obéir à ces
règles or acte après actes ces règles
sont bafoués les gens qui sont vus visé
au visage le sont de manière illégale
illégitime et illégale c'est ça mon
point de vue c'est à dire si la
république veut être respecté il faut
qu'elle se respecte elle même qu'elle
respecte elle même c'est ses propres
lois
donc moi les policiers qui m'appelle ils
sont plutôt de cette tendance là
et donc pour vous il ces policiers qui
vous contactent qui condamne bien sûr
ils condamnent ils sont effarés alors
c'est très clair le maintien de l'ordre
en fait il ya il ya deux cordes
il ya deux corps de police qui sont
formés ça qu'ils sont entraînés ces les
gendarmes mobiles d'un côté et ses
restes de l'autre tout le reste ce qu'on
vous allez voir ce que vous voyez vous
quand vous les films etc
c'est ce qu'on appelle la sécurité
publique c'est des gens qui sont dans
des commissariats à qui on dit samedi tu
fais maintien de l'ordre qui ne sont pas
formés pour ça il ya les gens de la bac
dont on va parler parce que je crois
qu'il ya vraiment un débat urgent à
ouvrir sur ces gens de là bas qu à qui
on demande de faire du maintien de
l'ordre et n'ont aucune formation
il faut absolument n'importe quoi
n'importe comment et moi les remontées
que j'ai les coups de fil que je peux
avoir de certains commando de deux crs
et ça va pas c'est pas comme ça que ça
va se passer
ils me font part de leurs de leur
fatigue de leurs exténuation etc
mais en fait le truc principal c'est que
les gens qui font du du maintien de
l'ordre
un moment donné il ya quelque chose de
d'un peu dégueulasse à les envoyer
samedi après samedi alors que la réponse
elle n'est pas policier
le caissier les questions qui sont
posées par les gilets jaunes sont
sociales et politiques donc la réponse
doit être politique et non pas
uniquement policière et ses policiers
justement qui vous parle on en entend
aussi du côté des policiers une forme
d'épuisement
je me souviens d'un commentaire d'un
syndicat alors qui est loin d'être
majoritaire dans la police de vichy
police qu'ils aient mais arrêtez de vous
servir des policiers comme dernier
rempart répondait d'un point de vue
social c'est un peu ça et a besoin dans
le réel état d'esprit un peu ces
policiers avec lesquels vous pouvez
parler comment comment ils ressentent
les choses on est quand même à la veille
d'une
jouant les mobiles 10e samedi consécutif
oui c'est quoi le ce qu'ils sont il ya
la fatigue il ya de la colère ou d'un
contrat il ya de la fatigue et c'est
logique et c'est normal qu'ils soient
fatigués je veux dire c'est des gens qui
sont sollicités depuis des années des
années constamment et c'est normal qu'il
soit fatigué par contre c'est tout à
fait inaudible qu'on nous dise que il y
à des bavures parce qu'ils sont fatigués
je veux dire des citoyens n'ont pas à
payer la balade la fatigue de la police
c'est tout là tout le raisonnement c'est
tout tout tout rôle des policiers qui
est en cause là est ce que la police
doit être absolument à ce point là
toujours mis en avant pour tous donc ils
me font part de leur fatigue ils vont
parle par dudu manque de commandement du
manque de commandement du manque de
formation
et puis il ya aussi certains policiers
alors ils sont plutôt minoritaire mais
qui sont sur la position du défenseur
des droits
défenseur des droits jacques toubon qui
a aujourd'hui même cet après-midi même
redit qu'il fallait retirer ses lanceurs
de balles de défense et ses flash ball
dans ans cadre dans le cadre du maintien
de l'ordre et paris juste ans et c'est
intéressant parce que ce flash ball
justement il est régulièrement évoqué
par ce qui est beaucoup de blessés des
manifestants qui ont perdu un oeil au
monde donc je crois que 14 oui à peu
près c'est difficile mais on est à peu
près dans la quinzaine en tout cas j'ai
créé la quinzaine de personnes qu'il ya
quinze personnes selon différents
décomptes qui ont perdu l'oeil qui ont
perdu un oeil et ça c'est des personnes
qui ont perdu avec l'utilisation d'un
flash ball alors en réalité le
flash-ball c'est une vieille armes qui
est à des années 90 aujourd'hui c'est
surtout son grand frère le lbd le
flash-ball c'était une fabrication
française qui ait des années 90 qui
était relativement imprécise qui a été
remplacé par une arme beaucoup plus
précise avec un viseur qu'est le lbd40
qui lui en plus permet d'envoyer des
projectiles plus loin justement les
fraudes est il quand on parle justement
de succès en plastique avec un bout de
caoutchouc ceux qui l'ont regardé fonds
directs on leur a montré un peu
ressembler à un flash ball et s'est
propulsée à combien de kilomètres heure
trois cent 300 km heure oui à partir de
quelle distance minimale fin ça peut
devenir une arme létale en dessous de 10
mètres en dessous des voix là parce que
dans la question est très importante
c'est à dire qu'en fait ses armes sont
vendues et vanté comme non létale c'est
à dire que a priori elles ne sont pas
faites pour tuer à une époque on disait
à létalité réduite c'est à dire ça tue
un peu moins bon ils ont changé ils ont
mis mon état depuis maintenant ça
s'appelle force intermédiaire à
l'origine l'idée qu'il ya derrière ces
armes
c'est en cas d'affrontement de
difficulté pour les forces de l'ordre
la possibilité d'immobiliser quelqu'un
parce que vous avez des charges très
forte
et puis vous pouvais plus marcher ou
vous vous écroulez etc et il ya des
règles il ya un manuel ce manuel a été
il y un matin rappelé par le dgpn
directeur général police nationale à ses
troupes en disant interdiction de viser
la tête et les parties génitales
le problème c'est que nous avons
quantité de vidéos de photos de gens qui
sont blessés à la tête
la question que je pose aujourd'hui
c'est est ce que ce chiffre là est due
au seul hasard ou pas est-ce qu'il est
dû au manque de formation est ce qu'il
est dû au fait qu'il y ait des gens qui
ne sont pas formés en maintien de
l'ordre qui utilisent ces armes est ce
que c'est la dangerosité de ces armes
comme le dit le défenseur des droits qui
fait qu' on en arrive là
et est ce justement aussi au niveau de
coût de cette arme en elle-même pour
essayer d'expliquer on parlait de la la
vitesse 300 km/heure fruits est ce que
le la visée est et précises ou
aléatoires serge jusqu'à quel nom le lbd
la visée est extrêmement précise donc il
ne peut y avoir aucune ambiguïté alors
dire que le viseur serait alors c'est là
la question c'est là la question c'est à
dire que le maintien de l'ordre c'est
des choses qui sont c'est une science
c'est une science quasi humaine c'est la
psychologie des foules c'est la gestion
des foules sait contenir des foules
c'est ça obéit à des règles dont on ne
l'imaginait pas forcément quand on est
face à des forces de l'ordre et quoi
encore moins quand on regarde des images
parce que il nous manque
il nous manque le
la vue globale pourquoi certains disent
qu'il ne faut pas utiliser ces armes là
en matière de maintien de l'ordre
je rappelle que seule la france en
europe utilisent à part quelques pays
mais en tout cas les pays comparables
angleterre-allemagne n'utilise
absolument pas ces arbres en matière de
maintien d'ordre parce que justement
c'est la foule la foule elle bouge
la foule a aussi fait la foule elle
court et on voit très bien dans les
dents les dents dans des dents les
images dans les vidéos bien souvent les
gens sont atteints alors qu'eux ils sont
en train de courir
ils sont atteints alors qu'ils sont ils
font ils ont tourné le dos ils partent
il fut et c'est donc le mouvement foule
est absolument incompatible avec le fait
de viser c'est tout simple or la france
continue à le faire alors que l'on
descende 2017 le défenseur des droits
avait recommandé le préfet de police de
paris
lui même avait dit qu'il n'utiliserait
plus ses armes dans le cadre du maintien
de l'ordre c'est documenté ce que je
vous dit et on s'est toujours le gars
s'est toujours fait donc aujourd'hui là
depuis depuis quelques heures c'est
devenu le grand débat entre nunez
castaner il ya des déclarations ici il
faut garder ces armes ne faut pas les
garder c'est pas eux qui disent assez
d'autres personnes etc
voilà là est la question se pose
aujourd'hui est il utile depuis combien
de temps parce que cinq ans on en fait
un focus particulier depuis le début du
mouvement des gilets jaunes parce que on
a vu et moi même j'ai constaté sur le
terrain
il est des blessures extrêmement graves
causés par ces lanceurs de balles ont
touché en pleine tête qui perdait
beaucoup de sang fin des images assez
assez choquant à chaque fois mais
finalement depuis quand ça existe et
pourquoi on n'en parle plus maintenant
qu'avant alors le flash ball va être
inventée dans les années va être arrivé
dans les années 90 au sein de la police
pas tellement pour le maintien de
l'ordre mais plutôt pour les
interpellations etc
et ensuite ça va être remplacé pour des
raisons techniques par le npd
progressivement il ya un tournant c'est
2007 ou à villiers le bel
suite à la mort de je ne sais plus
combien une ou deux personnes
il ya des émeutes urbaines c'est un
classique bavures policières émeutes
affrontements la france vit comme ça
depuis le début des années 80 et sauf
que là il ya un événement majeur c'est
que pour la première fois en matière de
main de violences urbaines ce qu'on
appelle une ancienne ou émeutes la
police va essuyer des tirs à balles
réelles et donc là la police va dire bon
à ce moment là on va être obligé de 2,2
de s'armer différemment et c'est donc
c'est là que le flash-ball et ses
dérivés vont vraiment entrer en action
mais je m'empresse de dire que les gens
qui sont touchés des gens que vous
filmez vous rémy qui sont en train de se
prendre une balle dans la tête
ils sont parmi c'est pas vrai c'est pas
vrai ils n'ont pas de cocktails molotov
c'est pas vrai monsieur nunez encore
aujourd'hui nous dit au sénat il ya la
volonté de tuer mais apportez-nous
l'épreuve combien de fusils de chasse
sont sortis 0 il y en a des millions en
france
donc s'il y avait vraiment une volonté
de tuer je pense qu'on le saurait tous
les affrontements soit extrêmement dur
qui est une violence qui est quelque
chose de de wiki qui peut s'apparenter à
l'insurrection à certains moments où à
l'affrontement
c'est vrai mais il ya dans la
dramatisation dans le vocabulaire est
employée régulièrement par
par une partie de l'appareil de l'état
quelque chose d'assez irresponsable je
trouve et ce que je pourquoi je vous
parle de ça parce que c'est pas du tout
la même chose que dans le cadre
d'émeutes liées des tirs à balles
réelles sur les policiers que les
policiers aient besoin d'être doté pour
répondre que des manifestations et on
voit bien qu'il ya un glissement à la
fois sémantique où on veut nous faire
croire que voilà les gens sont armés et
viennent pour tuer je veux dire c'est
quand même le discours des ministres
c'est quand même ce qu'on nous dit or
vous êtes sur le terrain tous les
samedis je me suis aussi est-ce que vous
avez constaté des gens qui voulaient
tuer des policiers
rémy il ya des violences mais alors
empressé difficile d'aller voir la
volonté des personnes au fond d'eux
mêmes mais on ne voit pas forcément une
volonté de tuer chez certaines personnes
voient là et il serait ce que je veux
dire c'est que les gens doivent aller
plus haut c'est vrai que pour compléter
le propos parce que vous posez la
question c'est vrai que dans l'appel de
la plupart des personnes qui sont
blessées sont souvent des personnes
extérieures à ces tensions
cqfd on prend le cas de lilian 15 ans à
strasbourg samedi dernier il sort de go
sport
il se prend à une bd on prend le cas de
ce pompier volontaire à voir là dedans
jour dans le jour comment depuis
quelques jours est toujours plongé dans
un coma artificiel depuis lundi depuis
lundi les images
puisqu'ils se trouvent cette scène a été
filmée par et à au moins 2 211 vidéo
peut être même trois tout cas deux j'en
suis certain qu'ils qui montre là qu'en
étant le manquement total de la
déontologie en matière de maintien de
l'ordre
voilà c'est le ce gilet jaune
il est rompu il est à bordeaux il est
repoussé par une charge policière
et ils se replient bon c'est le jeu au
classique etc
mais il ne présente aucun caractère de
danger mais les unes qu'un visage
réglementaire c'est à dire que oui on
sait quelles valeurs on aura l'occasion
si pareille de ce qu'on appelle plus
communément les grenades de
désencerclement dans quelles
circonstances elles doivent être
utilisés mais par rapport à ce flash
ball vu qu'on parle de cela maintenant
dans quelles circonstances peut-il être
utilisés on prend l'exemple du cas de à
bordeaux imaginons voilà il ya des
seuils à ces tensions
cet homme part en courant et rémy d'eau
ou non c'est vrai mais il n'y a pas de
tension c'est ça qui est extrêmement
éclairant aujourd'hui on a fait un petit
montage avec un camarade
j'ai mis sur mon fil twitter avec
l'autorisation de de stéphanie roy que
je je ne connais pas mais je félicite
qui est une caméra one absolument
extraordinaire qui sait voir qu'on salue
en effet quelle jeunesse indépendant de
très cher alors j'imagine vous la
connaissez mais qu'on croit son temps et
c'est aussi oui parce qu'ils aient
beaucoup de temps et je sais pas quel
âge est là mais elle est d'un courage
incroyable et elle va au front elle
ramène des images est ça qui est un
travail très précieux hors jeu pas par
elle-même et son plein d'autres joueurs
il a bien sûr le sol terra indépendant
dans les rédactions qui vont chaque
week-end pour essayer de vous donner des
images de ce qui se passe au plus proche
et c'est vrai que c'est si parfois tendu
parce qu'on se retrouve au milieu de
tensions qui peuvent parfois est
importante on peut se retrouver aussi de
charges policières aussi donc c'est coi
il faut qu'ils font et c'est à courage
voilà vous démontrez un crash fisichella
avec stéphanie ce qui est formidable je
t'appelle stéphanie murat n'est pas
c'est que en plus elle cadre c'est à
dire que ces images sont absolument
impeccable et qu'est ce qu'on voit
vraiment dans ces images-là de bordeaux
c'est que justement il n'y a pas de
tension il ya une charge crs qui est ou
ce gendarme mobile je sais plus mais qui
relativement calme qui fait ils font
leur boulot dispersion mais je dirais
qu'ils font leur boulot dans les règles
c'est à dire avec un certain calme et
une certaine retenue une certaine
contenance et c'est justement des
policiers en civil donc très
probablement la bac qui commettent qui
commettent l'acte convois sont des yeux
c'est à dire que il tire il vise divise
et c'est je crois la tempe droite mais
qui prend quelques le pompier volontaire
prend alors par rapport à votre question
très clairement le l'usagé de l'argent
elle c'est de se dire les règlements un
policier peut utiliser de façon manière
légale mais là là sont autorisés dans un
contexte particulier il ya il ya une
conduit il ya un conditions où il n'y a
pas de conditions c'est la légitime
défense
bon un policier qui se retrouvent en
légitime défense peu utilisé et compris
son arme de service
mais là on n'est pas du tout dans des
cas de légitime défense
on est dans des cas de maintien de
l'ordre d'affrontements de charges etc
le maintien de l'ordre en fait la
française il est gratuit
c'est il ya plusieurs étapes
l'étape ultime celle arme de service le
véritable fardeau on va dire le npd se
situe un peu au milieu
bon ce qu'on voit justement c'est qu'on
voit aujourd'hui des policiers qui
arrive déjà avec le lb des prêts avec
une armure et c c'est-à-dire que tout
l'effet psychologique du début qui est
de dire on montre sa force mais on s'en
sert pas on y va tranquillement et c est
complètement atténué par tout de suite
une image très très rude très dur du
policier qui peut s'expliquer pour des
raisons historiques
on pourrait revenir le lb d interdiction
formelle
c'est dans le sait dans le code c'est
dans le manuel sert quand vous avez un
stage parce que normalement vous est
habilité pour avoir levé le bd où vous
devez avoir fait un petit stage dans ce
pistage d un petit manuel et dans ce
petit manuel en vous dit interdiction de
viser les parties génitales interdiction
de viser la tête
c'est à dire qu'en gros il faut viser le
les membres supérieurs et deux membres
inférieurs et le buste bon on dit pas
s'il faut viser dans le dos moi je
reçois beaucoup de témoignages de gens
qui sont dont je vois les photos qui
sont visés dans le dos dire que un petit
peu compliqué de nous faire comprendre
que si des gens visés dans le dos
présenter un caractère de de menaces
sssa l'autre l'autre point c'est que
normalement c'est le commando sur place
qui donne qui donne ordre d'ailleurs
dans les dents les images de stéphanie
roy sur bordeaux on voit très bien qu'il
ya un policier qui a peu le chef un qui
décide de ce qui doit se passer
interdiction de faire moins de 10 mètres
parce que moins de 10 mètres
les lésions peuvent être irréversibles
même un risque pour la vie de la
personne selon l'endroit qui est visé
oui donc le risque pour cette personne à
mourir si c'est moins de 10 mètres alors
par exemple par des propos pour vous
répondre sur le s qui ait eu des
réponses à mes signalement par la place
beauvau
je constate que si le grand patron de la
police envoie un télégramme sa part est
à près de 18 mais en fait ça veut dire
que c'est un message de services en les
homos ne reçoit que tous les indices
reçoivent oui rappelle exactement ce que
je veux vous dire dans quel cadre ça
peut être utilisé voilà donc et ça peut
être utilisée normalement il doit y
avoir un sentiment de danger or parfois
il ya un sentiment de danger on voit
dans les images qui effectivement il ya
un affrontement c'est dur etc et que le
policier peut légitimement considérer
être en danger et c'est bon mais il ya
aussi quantité d'image où il n'y a pas
de danger et où l'armée et utilisées
alors que normalement il ne devrait pas
l'être
titah que l'on doit être utilisée
seulement dans un cas où il ya un danger
non pour le physique c'est l'intégrité
de ce monde c'est faussement c'est à
dire que le maintien de l'ordre en
france
il est basé sur deux principes
extrêmement important le premier c'est
l'absolue nécessité de l'usagé de la
force et le deuxième c'est la
proportionnalité c'est à dire est-ce que
c'est proportionnel et
ben c'est justement la question tout à
l'heure composé c'est à dire que est ce
que le lb des est une arme que le
concurrent direct le monsieur flash ball
messieurs flash ball a dit dans le
parisien
ollo le lb décès une arme de guerre ça
c'est ça fait des blessures de guerre
évidemment il ya probablement une
concurrence de marché mais il faut
entendre sa fabricant d'armes 10 de
l'autre que ce qu'il fait c'est quand
même des armes qui sont extrêmement
extrêmement dangereuse ce puisqu'on
disait on parlait juste ondes et de
l'utilisation de l'elysée oui absolument
et la proportionnalité voilà c'est ça et
est-ce que tirer avec un el bdc
proportionnelle est ce que on a plein de
l'image un manifestant hockey qui
refusent peut-être d'obtempérer
immédiatement quand on lui demande mais
qui parfois a les bras en l'air se met
devant les crs parce qu'il ya tout un
jeu comme ça de manifestations falla la
france est quand même un pays je le
rappelle toujours koala la fête
nationale c'est 14 juillet c'est la
prise de la bastille c'est un
affrontement ce conte ce qu'on célèbre
c'est quand même à l'affrontement
la france a toujours été comme ça et
est-ce que utilisé des armes aussi
puissante face à des manifestants qui
sont pacifiques
est-ce que c'est proportionnel la
réponse est non
mais ma réponse compte pas ce qui compte
c'est que les politiques s'en empare et
c'est en train de se passer
vous évoquez votre travail à l'instant
les six éléments que vous avez pu faire
il ya percée plusieurs personnes dans
les commentaires qui m'aurait voilà avec
le positionnement qu'il votera
aujourd'hui de faire remonter ces images
est ce que vous avez subi des pressions
non non non la salle des pressions des
menaces ou non non non non non non non
non non non et comment dire ça je crois
qu'il faut faut arrêter la parano le
travail bien fait quand votre travail
est inattaquable
on fait toujours tout discuter mais je
n'y a pas de pression
la pression c'est celle que je suis tout
seul un peu et que je suis fatigué et
que je suis submergé de notification de
choses comme ça mais non il n'y a aucune
pression politique et puis par ailleurs
alors là le jeu il est très très c'est
très classique c'est que partir du
moment où vous vous retrouvez un moment
donné relayée là comme c'est mon cas
depuis 48 heures de france culture à
brut de libération au figaro
la médiatisation provisoirement vous
vous vous protège des pressions voilà
imaginez que j'ai des pressions jeu les
balles entrer ici serait terminée dans
ce qu'ils feraient des pressions non il
n'y a pas de ya pas deux il n'y a pas de
pression
la pression est pour traiter premier à
en parler peut-être même de remonter ces
images en tant que journaliste à les
compiler les unes aux autres par des
tweets on dit oui de faire ce travail de
recension oui et alors il existe un
collectif qui s'appelle désarmons les
qui fait ce travail là depuis très
longtemps lui d'une manière plus
générale sur les violences policières
on a un peu il ya aussi un compte
twitter observatoire des violences
policières
c'est ce compte là qui avait révélé les
terribles images de de mantes-la-jolie
d'aider des lycéens
il ya quand même des gens qui font ce
travail là mais disons que sur les gilet
jaune
moi j'ai systématiser jeu systématise
c'est à dire que samedi je dormirai pas
dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche et je
mangerai peut-être pas dimanche parce
que je vais essayer de regrouper ses
environs et de recouper ces informations
si tenté que j'en ai à recouper
peut-être qu'il y aura pas
d'affrontement et tant mieux ça va
peut-être y aura pas de 2,2 me laisser
les emmener tant mieux vu en mai s'il y
en a je ferai le boulot j'irai jusqu'au
bout c'est clair lors ce qui est
important je regardais les commentaires
pour dire voilà on est avec david
dufresne qui est journaliste indépendant
et qui est spécialiste sur les questions
de maintien de l'ordre et qui depuis
notamment le début du mouvement des
gilets jaunes a recensé des cas de
violences policières dans des situations
des vidéos vous allez authentifié
récupérer postés sur les réseaux sociaux
avec ce halo place beauvau donc c'était
important aussi d'en bas d'en parler
dans les commentaires donc on parle
beaucoup de ces questions de maintien de
l'ordre c'est comparaison avec
l'étranger
vous faisiez référence tout à l'heure de
la comparaison avec l'allemagne riz et
l'angleterre
qu'est ce qui est différent et peut-être
même tout simplement aussi escale à un
exemple apprendre sur ce modèle alors on
parle de l'armement alors peut-être mais
cette première question est ce que là
bas en angleterre en allemagne est ce
qu'on est des flash ball lors dia bd des
grenades de désencerclement non non non
non on n'a rien de tout ça le maintien
d'ordre français pendant longtemps
s'exporter il se vendait parce qu'il y
avait un savoir faire qui était de
savoir faire naturelle d'un pays où la
contestation sociale fait partie de son
folklore fait partie de sa tradition le
mouvement gilet jaune
il est il et s'inscrit dans une dans une
dans une tradition là où il est
absolument remarquable c'est que il est
en rupture avec les les méthodes de
contestation qui avait jusqu'ici mais en
gros face à des manifestations
régulières la police et est aguerri
c'est à dire que chaque manifestation en
fait était comme un exercice de
perfectionnement pour la police donc la
police française s'est exportée
notamment sur le fait que en france
avait pas de morts y avait pas de morts
dans les cas de manifestations alors
hormis malik oussékine en 1986 et rémy
fraysse récemment qu'ils sont des
comment dirais-je des exceptions à la
règle
c'était plutôt c'est la chose était
plutôt vrai sauf qu'en fait la france
comme souvent nombriliste a cru qu'elle
était la meilleure du monde et que l
avaient pas à s'interroger tandis que en
allemagne en angleterre qui sont des
pays comparables c'est à dire qu'ils
sont des pays où il ya aussi des
manifestations sauvages des
manifestations non encadrés des
manifestation improvisée et qui sont
parfois extrêmement dur je pense au
black bloc et je pense aux néonazis pour
l'allemagne je pense aux hooligans pour
l'angleterre
eh bien figurez-vous que la cpo les
polices d'utilisable so lu ment pas ces
armes de force intermédiaire type
flashball grenade 10 ans et replantent
lbd et commence un seul un jardin du
coup c'est pas là cette question parce
que voilà je vois le profil black block
petit néonazis donc avec des profils qui
peut même parfois mener vers
attention même avec une vente et
d'affrontements avec les forces de l'anp
c'est ça comment efforts se répondent et
font en sorte que alors il pas trop
dégueulasse et le principe de la
désescalade
c'est à dire dd2 d'essayer de faire
baisser la tension
alors ça passe par des choses qui
peuvent paraître comme ça un petit peu
je serai intérêt je serais très
intéressé de voir dans les commentaires
est ce que les gens vont en penser mais
savoir si nous avions il y aura quelques
commentaires voilà ça passe par une
communication quasi permanente entre les
forces de l'ordre à des manifestants
communication qui paraissent notamment
par un truc étrange les réseaux sociaux
la police française n'utilise quasiment
pas les réseaux sociaux dans d'autres
pays au canada en allemagne en
angleterre
la police informe les manifestants voilà
ce qui va se passer
les sommations se font pas uniquement
avec un porte-voix comme en france mais
elles se font par des haut-parleurs
gigantesque elles se font par des
panneaux lumineux énorme qui disent
voilà ce qui va se passer
qu'est ce qu'on constate et je pense que
vous voyez vous dans les manifestations
c'est que bien souvent samedi dernier je
vais donner l'exemple qui est très
parlant 16h59 champs elysées on sait cap
généralement l'ordre de dispersion et à
17 heures bon un peu avant la nuit
tombée eh bien à 16h59 on voit un
gendarme mobile arrivée sur les champs
elysées au milieu prendre son porte-voix
et annoncer la sommation c'est-à-dire
force doit rester à la loi nous allons
utiliser les nous allons faire usage de
la force
il ya trois sommations puis de la
troisième à la charge
problème le porte-voix ne marchait pas
donc la foule se moquer falla fou le
premier rang se moquer du du policier
d'avoir change des piles donc voilà
c'est plutôt rigolo parlons c'est plutôt
rigolo mais en réalité ceux qui sont
deuxièmes au troisième
quatrième vidéo ils savent pas et donc
tout d'un coup il ya une charge tout
d'un coup il ya une charge
il n'y a pas une seule il ya eu
sommation mais cette sommation n'a pas
été entendu et bien vous avez
immédiatement effet de mouvement de
foule classique mais archi classique
c'est connu depuis le 19e siècle une
foule qui ne comprend pas ce qui se
passe et qui se retourne contre la
police qui devient ce que la police a
appelé une foule hostile
et ça c'est tout le temps c'est à dire
que les policiers explique mal explique
pas ce qu'ils vont faire
pour plein de raisons la première je
vous dis c'est que en termes de en
termes techniques
la police est encore avec des porte-voix
ridicule kiki donc qui n'ont pas voilà
alors ok en plus ça ne fonctionne pas
papa toujours je vous dis un porte-voix
qu'il fonctionne pas sur les
champs-elysées a quand même là il ya
quand même qu'il y fasse a fait un peu
amateur quoi mais en fait ce que je veux
dire c'est que derrière
est ce que ça signifie c'est que vous
avez une charge et vous avez des gens
qui comprennent pas qu'ils se sentiront
qu'ils n'ont pas eu le temps de 2-2-2 de
réfléchir à est ce que est ce que c'est
ce que je me retirais ce que je reste
c'est ce que je vais m'affronter ce que
je vais pas vous raconter et alors là
c'est parti c'est parti et puis et puis
là vous avez vous avez un retournement
donc la désescalade en allemagne en
angleterre c'est beaucoup ça c'est à
dire c'est une discussion qui se fait y
compris avec des décors qui ne sont pas
constitués salaires avec des mouvements
où il n'y a pas forcément de
représentants où il n'y a pas forcément
soit parce qu'ils sont dans l'illégalité
les néo nazis
soit parce que ils le refusent par
principe les black blocks
il ya quand même des discussions qui
peuvent qui peuvent être faites
et là si vous voulez en tant
qu'observateur de 2,2 du maintien de
l'ordre
j'avoue je suis comme certains
commandants qui m'appelle un petit peu
sidéré par ce qui est en train de se
passer c'est à dire que on a à peu près
les deux tiers des policiers qui font le
samedi du maintien de l'ordre
sans être formés à ça sans être
entraînés sans même être équipés moi
j'ai des policiers qui me disent que ils
vont
dans les surplus acheter leur matériel
de protection
donc évidemment ça ça va ça va créer un
climat mais c'est bon français on parle
des effets sur l'angleterre l'allemagne
serait nous expliquer maintenant et en
france ce serait quoi ce serait l'escale
en français aujourd'hui c'est
l'affrontement alors que pendant très
très longtemps le le principe tacite
s'était montré sa force pour ne pas s'en
servir alors il est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
et d'ailleurs on constate tous les
samedis la police du maintien de l'ordre
ne fait plus peur je veux dire moi je
suis quand même frappé par la
détermination que qui peut y avoir chez
certains manifestants à revenir tous les
samedis et à ne pas avoir peur de
quelque chose qui est pourtant sûr
équipé canons à eau l bd jean pierre
épaulières mousquetons bases qu'en
fermant toutes là tout là toute la
panoplie donc aujourd'hui oui la police
française le maintien de l'ordre
français il est beaucoup plus dans une
américanisation que dans une désescalade
est en fait le maintien de l'ordre
français il est il et il est dans la m
militarisation alors que historiquement
justement quand les ça peut être
intéressant pour les gens qu'ils
écoutent ces ils vont être surpris
les crs en fait ils sont nés après la
guerre
et parmi les crs vous aviez la la moitié
c'est des résistants et l'idée c'était
on ne va pas viser la foule on ne va pas
taper la foule et il fallait plus que ce
soit l'armée qui fasse le maintien de
l'ordre armées considérées comme trop
violente et donc on avait mis des
des crs en disant ils seront plus aptes
à contenir la foule le maintien de
l'ordre c'est bon après il ya des cas de
rétablissement de l'or ça c'est autre
chose
rétablissement de l'ordre c'est les
affrontements très dur des champs
elysées autour de la place de l'étoile
du 1er décembre dernier voilà alors là
on est dans l on est dans un autre ordre
autre chose mais ce dont on parle à tous
les deux enfin là en ce moment et avec
les 5500 personnes qui sont avec nous et
qu'il et voilà encore merci d'être là
sur cela et je m en c 2 voilà de fer
interactive et c'est assez intéressant
justement parce que il ya parfois si ce
commentaire qu'on a pu lire dans cela
élevé auquel parfois j'ai pu être
confrontés sûr de rien les gens là
qu'ils disent mais est ce que cette
répression policière elle a pas aussi
parfois une volonté de vouloir faire
peur aux manifestants sortir dans la rue
ah bah alors le sens où il y aurait la
peur pour certains de se dire j'ai peur
d'être blessé j'ai peur j'ai trop dans
des affrontements et laurent bon coup
parce que ça s'appelle la stratégie de
la tension
ça existe au début j'avais du mal à
imaginer c'était cette stratégie qui
était qui étaient mises en oeuvre
aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression que c'est
celle là oui si vous voulez il ya il ya
tout tout tout est fait pour tout de
même découragé les manifestants
quand un ministre annonce que des
policiers peuvent être tués
j'imagine qu'il ya plein de gens qui se
disent j'ai pas envie de me retrouver au
milieu de ça les images de violence
l'image d'un état violent et répressif
évidemment dans cette image est ce que
vous dites il ya cette idée de
décourager les une partie de la
population à venir manifester après je
crois absolument pas et qui est des
consignes de viser la tête ça je ne
crois pas mais pas du tout je pense que
les têtes certaines enfin parfois il ya
des têtes visé des têtes atteindre parce
que je vous dis on met beaucoup trop de
policiers qui viennent de n'importe où
qui sont pas formées avec des armes qui
ne devrait pas être là voilà donc
forcément aux multiples et là on a tous
les facteurs de risque et la stratégie
justement par rapport aux effectifs sur
le terrain alors on a parfois rendu qui
avaient des week-ends il est entre
guillemets trop de monde d'autres vous
n'avez pas assez est-ce que la stratégie
de dire on met 80000 force de leur
soutien comme c'était le cas la semaine
dernière je rappelle le dispositif qui a
été mis en place
88 for their sur l'ensemble du
territoire 5000 ne serait ce que sur la
capitale
est ce que c'est le fait de mettre le
plus de monde possible qu'ils aient une
bonne stratégie
alors moi des rôles avec mon analyse ce
fait l'arrêt alors déjà sur le lait sur
sous effet aussi sur off l'intérieur
ziad très clairement on est dans une
société de d'effets d'annoncé donc 80
mille salles à sa fiche sa fiche un peu
tout le monde
quatre conseillers non alors il est
clair que pour pour le
pour l'état c'est très compliqué parce
qu'il y a il y a je pourrais presque
dire et après il ya presque autant de
manifestations que le gilet jaune c'est
à dire que c'est pas il n'y a pas un
endroit à sécuriser ses pas bastille
nation à paris c'est partout c'est à
saint-etienne à montpellier il en est de
tomber dans des petites villes et c'est
donc forcément il faut il faut amener
pas mal de deux policiers
mais très clairement enfin me
semble-t-il oui on est dans des effets d
annonce qui essaient de décourager le
bafin qui essaient de décourager en
disant il ya risque vous vous allez
manifester il ya risque vont
manifestations ne sont pas déclarés donc
vous pourrez brutalisés en fait en gros
c'est ça que messager t on à cette
question dans les commentaires
alors je n'ai plus prénom je m'en
excuser cette personne mais qui a
précédemment nous ne pas être l'igpn un
fruit à avec avant de poser ses
questions peut-être tout d'abord savoir
le nombre donc alors on parlait des
décisions que vous avez fait mais
combien aujourd'hui est dedans cathy gpn
qui ont été ouvertes
alors je crois que le dernier chiffre
ses 83 ce qui est un chiffre à la fois
donc aller gpn enquête sur 83 cas 83
signalement de manquement à la
déontologie du matière noire
c'est beaucoup et c'est très peu parce
que dans le même temps on a le ministère
de l'intérieur qui du bout des lèvres
nous dit il ya entre eux il ya à peu
près mille 700 blessés
moi je reçois aussi parmi les emails je
reçois des gens qui ont des pions porter
quand on fait des signalements igpn dont
les enquêtes sont pas forcément ouvert
83 c'est plus que dans n'importe quel
autre mouvement social je note aussi que
ça s'ouvre de plus en plus c'est à dire
que tous les jours il ya des enquêtes
alors qu'il a fallu attendre quasiment
un mois pour de mémoire pour apprendre
qu'il y avait une vingtaine d' enquêtes
ouvertes aujourd'hui on en a 83 serre
que tous les jours il y en a entre 5 et
10 nouvelles et c'est assez c'est assez
considérable donc léger pnc la police
des polices c'est une police qui n'est
pas tellement aimé de la police
c'est une police qui qui fait son boulot
mais qui est juge et partie
voilà qui est juge et partie donc c'est
travailler beaucoup à cette question là
c'était la question de cet internaute
oui assure à l'indépendance de l'igpn
parce que où notre foi ce commentaire de
justice à deux vitesses alors certains
le prennent avec d'autres exemples
peut-être l'occasion d'en parler aussi
mais de dire qu'aujourd'hui un
manifestant qui va commettre une action
violente
quelle qu'elle soit sera plus facilement
réprimer ou plus fortement qu un
policier qui blesse vraiment une
personne déjà est ce que ces
indépendants et qu'est-ce qu'on réagit
lario il alors
il est évident que la répression
judiciaire elle s'abat de manière
terrible sur les manifestants en ce
moment je veux dire que le nombre de
jugements rendus qui vont dans ce sens
là est incroyable
le policier si vous voulez
d'abord il a des circonstances
atténuantes puisque il est policier donc
il a il est le représentant de ce qu'on
appelle vulgairement le monopole
légitime de la violence a priori seul
policier dans un certain cadre a le
droit d'être violon un interpellé ça
peut être violent pour le problème c'est
le degré de violence 1 est ce que cette
crs sur un individu
c'est acceptable bien sûr que non donc
oui très clairement les policiers sont
beaucoup moins poursuivi mais il faut
pas croire qu'ils ne le sont pas c'est à
dire que parce que moi je lis beaucoup
de commentaires qui disent non jeu ça
sert à rien et gpn
non c'est pas vrai c'est pas vrai il ya
des enquêtes qui vont au bout il ya dix
ans quel qui vont au pénal ce qui est
vrai c'est que au pénal des policiers
condamnés c'est très très rare
mais avant d'aller au pénal il ya aussi
tout un tas de sanctions administratives
des avancements qui n'avance pas des
placardisation des révocations et
je serais tenté de dire que si des gens
estiment de bonne foi avoir été victime
d' agences d'agissements illégitime de
policiers je crois pas je crois pas que
ce soit bien de se décourager de déposer
plainte et les gps non l'igpn
ils ont justement qu'elle a eu mafalda
conseil dans les commentaires plus
diriger peine à les passer sous
l'autorité de qui a peu d'elle-même
il n'y a pas de voile à l'igpn c'est la
police des polices mais y'a pas elle est
ensuite six avec beaucoup de son
indépendance dresser les policiers qui
ont contrôle d'autres comment on peut
éviter leur connivence il même un
traitement impartial pour aller très
vite iman l'enquète et ensuite ils
peuvent soit faire des décisions
administratives soit c'est au pénal
c'est à dire qu'ensuite c'est la justice
est d'ailleurs sur les sur les 83
dossier-là actuellement
je crois que la plupart en fait c'est
des procureurs qui ont saisi ses
parkings saisi l'igpn 11 ans vous devez
enquêter vous devez travailler
vous devez travailler là dessus mais en
fait je je sais qu'il ya une forte
suspicion par rapport à l'igpn olivier
et je serais tenté de dire que c'est
évidemment il ya la réparation
judiciaire qui est importante pour les
victimes
mais pour tous les gens qui ne sont pas
victimes il ya aussi le débat public
autour de ces questions là autour du
maintien de l'ordre et sont des
questions politiques qui concerne
absolument tout le monde et porter
plainte
c'est aussi une façon de porter le débat
est sur l'aboutissement justement de ces
plantes est ce qu'on a est ce qu'on peut
mettre en perspective par exemple par
rapport à d'autres voilà des personnes
qui seraient interpellés pour de la
violence envers les policiers de l'autre
côté ces procédures et ce qu'on a un
pourcentage de procédure par exemple au
niveau du gpu qui irait au bout parce
que voilà c'est ce que j'ai tenté enfin
les commentaires c'est à dire est ce
qu'aujourd'hui ces procédures elles sont
vraiment mener jusqu'à leur terme à
mettre justement emparée avec ceux qui
seront interpellés dont quant aux
sentiers ouverts
je serais tenté de dire c'est que les
cas sont relativement grave et que tu as
dit gp ne peuvent pas faire autrement
voilà c'est plutôt avant un c'est plutôt
avant alors moi je suis je ne suis pas
avocat je sais pas conseiller juridique
mais il est évident que par exemple si
la police admettons vous êtes blessé
pour trouver à l'hôpital parce que vous
avez été visés au visage et s'inquiète
pour votre oeil et que vous voyez les
policiers arriver si vous avez envie que
les gp n aille au bout et bien gardé le
silence et puis attendez de voir votre
avocat pour ensuite aller faire votre
déposition auprès de la police
car si la police recueille votre
déposition et que sur votre lit
d'hôpital je le dis parce que j'ai dû
une plainte comme ça au détour d'une
phrase quelqu'un qui a été victime d'un
tir de la bd dit je pense que les
policiers se défendent et c'est un peu
fini d'affaires sera très vite classé
donc ce que je veux dire c'est que là
encore c'est toujours la même chose
c'est une question de règles et de droit
c'est à dire que faut faire les choses
bien
faut aller voir des avocats il faut
connaître un petit peu le droit faut pas
se précipiter
il faut bien déposer sa pinte si on
considère que la plainte doit être
déposée faut alerter les avocats faut
alerter la presse et dans un pays comme
le nôtre la justice peut être rendu
alors évidemment la justice sera pas
exactement toujours la même de ce long
mais ça c'est vieux comme comme jean de
la fontaine peu de clémence
oui voilà bien sûr bien sûr je je
battrai clairement prenons prenons le
cas entre christophe
le boxeur qui est en prison et en
détention à des dangers ravisera
expliqué pour ce commerce ça s'est passé
donc sur un pont le 5 janvier dernier
christophe dettinger qui s'est rendu de
lui-même police trois jours après parce
qu'il accusait il ya une perquisition
chez lui et n'a été retrouvé mais c'est
surtout sur les violences qui ont été
commises à l'encontre de deux gendarmes
sur des gendarmes sur le pont on a vu
ces images qui ont fait le tour de la
planète tellement elle était
impressionnée impressionnante et même
inattendu parce que c'est vrai que c'est
rarement des violences mais et de cette
raison elle est donc passé en détention
provisoire en attente de son de sang
dans son jugement qui aura eu dans les
prochaines semaines c'est ça il est
logique illogique que justice passe 1 et
que tu es le policier porte plainte et
que d'étrangers il est un avocat écueil
est bon mais dans le même temps on a le
même jour à toulon un commandant de
police qui est également filmé en train
de boxer à deux reprises
donc le même geste
la boxe bat lui il n'est pas en
détention provisoire moi je suis pour
occulter tension pour vous je veux dire
que dans ces cas là je veux dire des
étrangers lui il se rend à la police
donc le risque que ils ne viennent pas à
son procès quand même extrêmement faible
puisqu'il fait le geste de se rendre lui
même à la police
c'est là où je dis ait deux poids deux
mesures c'est à dire que pour le même
geste
vous avez un qui est en détention
provisoire et l'autre qui n'est pas tout
à fait inquiète et donc ça la la ça
participe s'il voulait à l'injustice ça
participe alors on sort du cadre du
maintien de l'ordre mais ces deux c'est
la deuxième couche c'est à dire c'est
judiciaire quand on a le le le procureur
du var qui immédiatement après les
affaires de toulon tombe du commando
andrieu qui tout de suite dit il ya pas
matière à enquête
je peux comprendre que les gens qui nous
regardent se disent à quoi ça sert bon
eh bien figurez vous que quand même le
préfet lui s'entend quand même qu'il y
avait g anguille sous roche
s'est senti obligé de saisir pour le
coup les gps qui va faire son travail
voilà donc voilà donc et cette question
c'est qui qui se posent en dans les
commentaires certains réagissent à une
personne qui avait souhaité porter
plainte contre des propos de luc ferry
oui à est ce qu'aujourd'hui un
commissariat peut refuser une plainte
d'un point de vue légal c'est un
quelqu'un dans un commissaire dit je
veux porter plainte quelle que soit la
raison qu'elle soit valable ou pas
derrière mais est ce que le policier
peut dire aux gens là on va dire ben oui
si c'est pas c'est pas crédible alors je
sais qu'il ya une vidéo autour de ça
mais je n'ai pas regardé au taux
nettement je veux je veux pas me le jeu
peut pas répondre je ne sais rien voilà
jeu honnêtement aux questions j'en sais
rien mais c'est tout ce domaine doivent
faire justement bah voilà même la
réponse non je vais pas je vais pas
inventer quoi je vais pas inventer
voilà sept cette question à les
commentaires qui est intéressant de tir
qui nous parle du raid et des canons à
eau
oui c'est vrai qu'il ya eu cette
polémique par rapport aux canons que je
l'utilisé le 1er mai où certaines
informations avait révélé le fait qu'il
y avait des restes de d'animaux à
l'intérieur de ce qui était projeté sur
les personnes mais est ce que c'est ce
qu'il est un cadre légal justement dans
l'utilisation du canon à eau est ce que
est ce qu'il ya aussi des informations
sur la la composition de ce qui est
alors ça a été démenti
ça a été démenti
c'était très surprenant ça a été démenti
je sais pas exactement là encore ouais
ouais ouais ce qu'on en est par rapport
à ça par contre ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que le canon à eau
aujourd'hui il est utilisé de manière
rapide et fréquente alors qu'en réalité
le canon à eau dans la graduation dont
je vous parlais tout à l'heure c'est
assez haut
sans jeu de mots c'est même très haut
dans la graduation donc là aussi ça
participe de d'une démonstration martial
des forces de l'ordre il ya des images
de samedi dernier est terrible on voit
la propulsion tel qu'un corps est
complètement jeté se retrouve plaqué
contre 1 contre contre la bouche de
métro etc
enfin je veux dire de canon c'est pas du
tout c'est le jeu les connu à plusieurs
reprises et je voyais c'est vrai que la
puissance du g est extrêmement forte et
enfin moi je pourrai jamais dépend
l'avoir reconnu à plusieurs reprises
peut vous faire tomber au sol même ces
mêmes vous bouger les bus ça devrait
vous lui ça peut vous traîner sur votre
essai sur plusieurs mètres sur plusieurs
mètres absolument rue mais oui cic
c'est considérable et s'ils voulaient ce
qui est un peu étonnant c'est que
normalement le canon à eau il est
utilisé vraiment à la fin et là il est
il est utilisé au milieu on va dire des
moddeurs ce que je veux dire c'est que
parce que je comprend ce qu'est ce que
sous-entend 7 cette question et en plus
il met des produits etc
il n'y a même pas besoin d'aller dans
des choses comme ça il faut regarder les
règles est ce que les règles sont
appliquées elles ne le sont pas voilà on
est voilà c'est le débat et ils
s'opposent déjà au premier niveau
c'est intéressant justement cette cette
réponse aux questions des internautes y
en a aussi plusieurs qui nous paraît d'
de la responsabilité au niveau de l'état
par rapport à ce qui se passe
actuellement sur le terrain vous évoquez
s'est blessé on parle de 1700 blessés
environ du côté des manifestants
mille du côté des forces de l'ordre donc
c'est un chiffre impressionnant mais qui
a la responsabilité de
de cela derrière à c'est très compliqué
on ne peut pas traîner je ne crois pas
qu'on puisse traîner en justice à un
ministre pour mise en danger d'autrui
je pourrais simplement dire que le
préfet grimaud qui était le préfet qui
commandait les forces de l'ordre en mai
68 à paris avait écrit aux forces de
l'ordre une lettre restée célèbre que
vous pouvez retrouver par exemple sur le
site du monde qu'il a acquis la ville
qui l'a remise dans laquelle il disait
et frappé un homme à terre c'est se
frapper soi même on avait à ce moment là
des gens dans l'appareil de l'état qui
avait quand même un sérieux sens de
responsabilité là on à christophe
castaner qui à deux reprises hier et
avant-hier a nié les violences
policières et les a niées il est dans le
déni
j'estime que on peut pas le poursuivre
pour ça c'est des idées donc les idées
peuvent s'exprimer etc
mais je pense qu'on peut la culée sur
cette question là c'est à dire jusqu'où
on va ni ces violences policières
donc qu'ils peuvent être si vous passez
que celui qui est pénalement responsable
il finit ses policiers et éventuellement
le donneur d'ordre mais la question elle
est à mon sens plus intéressante si on
la porte au niveau politique c'est à
dire qu'est ce qu'on fait de l'espace
public c'est quoi la gestion de l'espace
public c'est quoi la gestion d'une
manifestation
voilà et on a aujourd'hui à l'oeuvre une
réponse qui est extrêmement dur
et de ce point de vue là on peut
interroger les ministres apparence de
cette grenade de désencerclement ils
utilisent et règlements qui est là aussi
alors allez moins dans l'actualité en ce
moment parce que c'est vrai que les
luttes et très concernés autour du flash
ball 7 gold désencerclement déjà dans
quel cadre elle peut être utilisée et on
parle beaucoup si de sa composition
c'est grave explosive en quelque sorte
alors oui il ya plusieurs grenades et la
d1 certainement mais celle dont on parle
surtout c'est la gli f4 qui est une
grenade qui composait de 25 grammes de
tnt
son but qu'un explosif
ah oui et et voilà pour tnt oui c'est
pas c'est pas que c'est pas de la télé
quoi la cdc l'autre quoi c'est la voilà
et donc elle cette grenade à la 2è l'a22
intérêts
c'est l'effet de souffle et le bruit
sans 65 décibels serre qu'elle a fait à
peu près le même bruit qu'un avion même
un peu plus qu'un avion au décollage
donc c'est une c'est une grenade qui est
extrêmement forte
un petit peu moins forte que celles qui
étaient utilisés jusqu'ici et qui avait
tué rémy fraysse quelques avait atterri
dans son sac et qu'il l'avait tué il
avait abattu sept grenades avait
absolument pas utiliser ailleurs en
europe
cette grenade elle est faite alors elle
fait partie vraiment de l'arsenal
du très haut là c'est à dire qu'elle est
elle est faite pour les moments de très
très haute tension et elle est quand
même pas mal tiré pas mal utilisé et là
encore à à mon sens on sort du sacro
saint principe du maintien de l'ordre
qui est la proportionnalité voilà est-ce
que vraiment alors en plus maintenant il
ya des là aussi les images qui sont
tournées on voit qu'elles sont parfois
envoyer ses grenades n'importe comment
c'est à dire que normalement ils doivent
être envoyées au ras du sol
c'est pourquoi elle blesse au pied 1
parfois quand elle blesse mais on les
voit aussi lancer maintenant en l'air au
dessus de la foule en cloche
ce qui est extrêmement dangereux et du
coup on a des blessés par des grenades à
la tête aux épaules alors que ça ne
devrait pas arriver ici moi donc ça
c'est une réponse qui est important sur
ce sujet parce que vous étiez nombreux à
en parler dans l'est dans les
commentaires il ya cette question qui se
pose aussi sur ce maintien de
l'engouement faisait état de 2 s'est
blessé extrêmement important des deux
côtés comment les forces de l'anp
peuvent-ils réussir à avoir une réponse
proportionnée et éviter ces images
justement de blessés graves
quand certaines personnes peuvent aussi
vouloir les jours trouver cet équilibre
parce que ça que c'est cette question on
parlait de l'exemple de l'allemagne
alors j'ai angleterre moi je vous
renvoie aux déclarations de certains
syndicats de police
lundi lundi pas à lundi dernier mais
celui d'avant quand edouard philippe est
invité au journal de 20 heures de tf1 où
il annonce qui aura 80 mille policiers
dans les rues en france pour l'acte 9
celui de samedi dernier
il est 20h15 à 20h16 il ya un tweet du
syndicat des commissaires qui nous dit
gilet jaune contre c'est pas les gilles
jaune c'est pas un match de foot c'était
ça le terme
gd je ne sais pas policiers contre gilet
jaune c'est pas un match de foot c'est
par la concertation et le dialogue qu'on
s'en sortira je je je vous dirais les
policiers qui viendront samedi ils
viendront pas avec des fleurs c'est
évident c'est pas ça leur métier c'est
parce que c'est parce que les gens
attendent de la réponse si on veut
éviter les images par rapport à votre
question si on veut visiter éviter des
images de blessés mais surtout si on
peut éviter les blessures les
mutilations assez simplement qu'une
réponse politique concrète et réelle
les causes du désordre ne seront
toujours là ce verset pas parce que la
police sera répressive que le mouvement
va cesser de lui même les raisons de sa
de la gronde sont toujours là donc elles
n'ont pas de réponse politique
donc moi je suis pas du tout stratège je
suis pas conseiller du ministre je n'ai
pas à dire ce que les policiers ont à
faire parce que c'est un échec du
maintien de l'ordre dans la totale arbas
total mais déjà le terme de maintien de
l'ordre à la française en réalité faut
l'oublier
il faut l'oublier parce que c'est le
mythe dans lequel où on a versé renoncer
on sait bercé on s'est fait verser le
dont on parlait au début de ce maintien
de l'ordre
sûr de sa superbe de sa supériorité
parce que il n'est pas parce qu'il
faisait pas de mort etc
à propos de mort je voudrais quand même
signaler que l'igpn enquête toujours sur
ce qui s'est passé à marseille sur cette
dame est décédée après des tirs de
grenades dans les temps le fermer son
volet c'est à marseille
cette personne âgée a reçu des
lacrymogènes qui lui était pas destiné
les citoyens jugés sur l île en est
décédé après plusieurs tours voilà à
l'hôpital donc
pour l'instant on n'a pas de certitudes
l' enquête avance progresse mais à
l'heure du bilan il faudra bien voir si
aux comptes
cette dame comme une victime du maintien
de l'ordre est il victime des
débordements du maintien de la radio on
en est et où ça on parle justement de
l'échec de les jouer ce qui pour vous
c'est un échec du maintien de leurs de
la chaîne bien sûr et du mythe du
matière d'or à la française
voilà cette idée que ben voilà ça tue
pas et ses doudounes 1,6 sur la sueur
sur sur marseille maintien d'ordre à la
française pour moi il a explosé en plein
vol en tout la celui qui était qui ce
qui était longtemps considéré qu'il se
considérait comme dans l'excellence vous
aviez c'était c'était assez amusant
il ya une quinzaine d'années vous aviez
deux pôles d'excellence dans la police
vous aviez la police judiciaire et puis
vous aviez le maintien de l'ordre
le reste est pas mon notamment par
exemple police de proximité patrouille
c'était très mauvais mais effectivement
il y avait une limite du quai des
orfèvres
voilà et puis il y avait le maintien
l'ordre aujourd'hui le maintien leur dit
c'est de mon point de vue le maintien de
la française cette idée là a explosé en
plein vol
on est dans autre chose
est ce que on est dans un moment parce
qu on est dans un moment extraordinaire
social extraordinaire au sens strict du
terme avec le mouvement des gilet jaune
est ce que le maintien de l'ordre est au
milieu du gué et entre deux options
j'en sais rien est ce qu'il est dans une
option extrêmement dur je le crains
quand le canard enchaîné révèle mercredi
que
les fusils d'assaut que certains ont pu
voir à paris à nantes
utilisez alors n'ont pas utilisé ils en
ont pas ils en ont pas ils s'en sont pas
servis mais en tout cas on était comment
dirais-je montrer exhiber c'est un ordre
ministériel c'est très clair et la
laideur comment on explique que ces
armes soient présentes voilà par exemple
sur cet acte 9 et qu'elle ne l'est pas
été sur les huit précédentes parce que
on est dans si vous voulez c'est le
principe même du maintien de l'ordre
c'est à dire il ya ce principe de l'
escalade et là je porte dans mon point
de vue c'est surtout de l'image 1 c'est
surtout une là encore de créer un effet
de sidération avec d'un côté ce climat
de tension sur le terrain moi même en
tant que joueur sur le terrain on a vu
que alors certes il ya des tensions
temps à autre on est quand même bien
loin de ce qu'on avait pu voir le 24
novembre le premier des 5 ou 8 décembre
et c'est justement là est la question
qui se pose c'est de se dire pourquoi ça
apparaît en beau milieu du mois de
janvier
le 12 janvier je pense je pense qu'à une
forme de une forme de comment dirais-je
d'improvisation
faut pas oublier on a on a un changement
de ministre de l'intérieur
peu de temps avant le mouvement des
gilets jaunes donc est-ce que la
passation de pouvoir s'est faite comme
il fallait
d'un point de vue de l'ordre pas sûr on
a une préfecture de police de paris
extrêmement affaibli par la sphère
benalla la sphère benalla qui de mon
point de vue explique beaucoup de choses
parce que l'histoire des idées des
passeports tout ça c'est exotique mais
c'est pas ça la ferme et à la sphère
benalla au départ c'est un proche du
président de la république qui exercent
de manière illégale du maintien de
l'ordre
donc d'une certaine manière à son niveau
individuel il annonce ce que moi je vois
c'est à dire cette utilisation
il légitime de certaines armes dans des
voies là sans respect pour la doctrine
d'emploi etc ou simplement le fait que y
ait une utilisation de deux cas une
possibilité d'utilisation de césar voilà
donc moi je pense que c'est dès le fusil
d'assaut c'est c'est évidemment de
l'image quoi voilà c'est vraiment lien
avec les manifestants certains pensaient
que c'était un lien avec le risque de
terroristes parce que c'est vrai aussi
ces images de certains qui ont pu voir
des snipers à certains moments et qui
pensaient que c'était dirigé vers des
manifestants est-ce que c'était le cas
où est-ce que c'était plutôt sur un
autre type de menace je suis pas dans le
secret des dieux encore moins en ce
moment
il est évident que je serais intéressé
là aussi d'avoir les retours des gens
qui nous regardent
il est évident que cette société qui
depuis 15 ans 20 ans est en demande de
sécuritaire qui accepte que année après
année les libertés individuelles et
collectives recul pour des raisons qui
sont parfois l'antiterrorisme c'est à
dire que au nom de l'antiterrorisme qui
est une cause partagée
on est un peu moins de droit et que on
voit des policiers faire dans le cadre
de ce qu'ils appellent opération
sentinel se promener dans les grandes
gares des grandes villes avec des fusils
mitrailleurs avec des choses comme ça
etc
il ya cette idée d' acclimatation de on
s'accommode de ces questions là et je
pense que ce qui ce qui a été voulue
dans le fait d'envoyer ses fusils
c'était effectivement une façon de dire
voyez y aille
il ya danger mais on s'en occupe voilà
de la même manière qu'il ya danger on
s'en occupe on patrouille dans les gares
etc
et moi j'ai des crs qui m'explique
justement le le fait que
ce qui s'appelle entre la tenue robocop
soit devenu quasiment la tenue de
travail au quotidien fait que
aujourd'hui des manifestants face à des
robocop n'ont plus peur puisque c'est
robocop on les voit toute la journée
dans l'année pour patrouiller dans le
cadre d'opérations sentinelle et c'est
donc tout ça montre que on est dans un
dans un moment
d'un point de vue du maintien de l'ordre
de à mon avis de bascule complet c'est à
dire qu'elle est ce qu'on va aller dans
une très forte militarisation canons à
eau
les blindés les fusils ou est ce
qu'avant donné on va faire un pas en
arrière
aujourd'hui le défenseur des droits
demande la suspension de l'usaj dl bd en
maintien de l'ordre
on verra samedi samedi la réponse on
attend d'eux répond justement du côté du
ministère de l'intérieur
il ya une question qui a vu très souvent
dans les commentaires par rapport à
l'identification des forces de l'ordre
sur le terrain
oui sur la question du matricule oui à
aujourd'hui
est ce que le matricule il est
obligatoire
il est totalement obligatoire
c'est à dire que
[Musique]
sauf dans des opérations de d'élite type
reggie gêne ou dans des opérations de 2
à temps on va dire ah bon on va dire ce
qui se passe on va dire ce qui se passe
on va être honnête parce que ça fait
voilà ça fait une heure 1h16 qu'on est
con et en live et on vous remercie david
dufresne et c'est bien de faire du temps
long parce qu'on dit justement c'est un
format que qui est super intéressant
parce que ça permet d'aller au fond des
choses de vous les 76 de vous exprimer
lizotte a largement été mis en garde
ayant déjà d'orgue comprennent
en fait j'écris a réuni son sauveur
voilà j'ai écrit que jamais vous on est
allé aux toilettes
du coup je peux garder je me gardais
long terme pendant quelques secondes
pour les garder derrière lui paraît pas
évident quelques secondes mais oui je
faisais juste la mémoire mais je vais
juste répondre je vais juste répondre le
pas ce que c'est et sont extrêmement
importantes le battery tude c'est à dire
qu'en effet n'importe quel policier en
terre en matière de l'ordre doit être
anthouard on doit pouvoir savoir qui qui
agit
[Musique]
et d'être identifiable
donc par exemple un policier qui a n'a
pas de matricule qui en plus est un
masque et hors la loi sauf sauf donc je
voulais lire sauf dans le cadre des
opérations d'élite raid ggn ou anti
terrorisme pour des raisons évidentes
voilà et parfois dans des missions de
renseignement mais là c'est très où il
ya le secret défense
mais très clairement un un policier qui
fait du maintien de l'ordre doit être
identifiable et par rapport à ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure sur la désescalade
vous verriez les uniformes des
équivalents de crs gendarmes mobiles en
allemagne mais les matricules sont
visibles sont très visibles et justement
cette bosse voiteur cette question que
qui se pose on parle du matricule
certains reprochent à certains membres
des forces de l'ordre d'avoir le visage
masqué voyez ce qu'aujourd'hui les
forces de l'ordre ont le droit d'être
sur le terrain en ayant en portant une
cagoule et en ne voyant que leurs
glorieux non là c'est délicat parce que
l ombre par exemple des crs qui
balancent des gaz lacrymo tout le monde
le voit avant de c'est d'ailleurs un peu
le signal avant d'envoyer des gaz ils
mettent des masques bon des masques pour
respirer pour pouvoir respirer bon voilà
ça c'est légal
par contre un masque porté par un type
de la bac dame de la bac
c'est totalement interdit c'est
totalement et d'ailleurs par exemple
parmi les signalements j'avais j'avais
remonté je crois que ça se passait à
toulouse
un policier qui avait eu cru amusant de
se grimer enfin d'avoir pour ma pour
masquer une espèce de tête de mort
d'après ce que j'ai cru comprendre pour
le coup ses collègues savent qui il
était et je crois qu'à une petite
enquête c'est totalement interdit bien
entendu c'est totalement interdit je
veux dire le le le le policier il est au
service du citoyen il n'est pas contre
le citoyen donc il doit être
identifiable
je veux dire que d'autant qu'il est
responsable comme chacun pénalement
donc oui bien sûr et pourquoi il n'est
pas identifiable
c'est évident a évidemment pour éviter
les poursuites c'est uniquement ça
puisque c'est la première chose qu'on va
vous demander quand vous irez vous iriez
à l'aller gpn c'est bon alors le
policier dont vous nous dites qu'il vous
a agressé connaissez vous son nom non
connaissez vous son matricule non avez
vous des photos ah oui mais ouais mais
il est masqué ça va pas être facile
petite pause petite pause mais j'en ai
fait je garde l'antenne en jeu
j'explique beaucoup de fulda ceux qui
l'ont regardé exactement 20h13 vous
voyez c'est la magie du direct et petite
pause pendant quelques instants on est
donc avec david dufresne pour ceux qui
viennent de nous rejoindre
il est journaliste à répondre à elle et
à travailler il ya quelques années dans
différentes rédactions il est
spécialiste des questions de maintien de
l'ordre
et ben on a voulu l'inviter sur brut
aujourd'hui pour justement parler des
des manifestations du maintien de
l'ordre en france dès des blessés aussi
qu'on a pu voir même nous mêmes sur le
terrain moi même jour à ispoure brut de
voir des personnes qui avaient plus de
blessés par des tirs de flash ball à la
tête
belle idée c'était ben justement d'avoir
son témoignage son ressenti lui qui
début depuis le début de ce mouvement d
gilet jaune recense sur les réseaux
sociaux dont sur son compte twitter
david dufresne il expliqué recense
justement cck 2
de violences policières dont kylie
chèque chaque week-end il est présent
sur les réseaux sociaux ils récupèrent
ces images fait son travail de
journaliste derrière pour les identifier
pour les authentifier
et voir que ça correspond bien des
éléments qui sont déroulés dans la
journée en france est clairement
identifiable
donc on va en parler avec lui et puis on
vous remercie d'être là on sera là ça ni
bien sûr sur le terrain pour ceux qui
alors je vais pas je vais pas mettre à
la place moi je suis très bien où je
suis et je si je me met à chanter je
pense que l'audience divisera par deux
donc on va éviter
mais d'ores et déjà samedi on sera
ensemble poursuivre l'acte l'acte 10 des
défilés jaune on a suivi les neuf
précédents on sera présent samedi sur le
terrain pour vous faire vivre la
mobilisation en direct les images des
slogans les interviews témoignages
l'ambiance sur place comment il a pu
faire durant les neuf autres semaine
précédente
on sera là et ben voilà on fera notre
boulot directement au coeur sur le
terrain de deux journalistes et à vous
donner c'est à ces images ces réactions
et 7 cette ambiance appareils pour le
10e samedi consécutif de mobilisation
j'ai tenu un brave et j'ai pu parler un
peu de ce que de la suite des événements
de la couverture de samedi comme les
neuf samedis précédents alors là on est
combien alors là est à peu près 4000 cas
d'une personne qui l'on garde qui sont
là présente toujours sur ce live qu'on
remercie vous êtes de plus de 100000 à
nous avoir suivis en cumulé depuis début
cela et on vous en remercie ben voilà de
suivre ce live on essaye justement de
donner la parole sur le long pour aller
au fond de ces questions qui sont des
questions importantes qui demandaient
des développements et on essaie
justement de de les avoir dans ce
directeur on parlait donc juste avant
cette petite pause de des matricules des
visages est ce que ces visages peuvent
être dissimulés n'ont pas pareil donc la
réponse a été donnée l'occasion
peut-être de de répondre aussi à
plusieurs questions dans les
commentaires
alors où nous mêmes ou en tant que
tous les ans on peut on pourrait même y
répond nous mêmes sur certaines
informations qui passait sur les eaux
sociaux et qui s'avèrent inexactes
notamment sur salle de gaz lacrymogènes
qui ont été envoyées d'hélicoptères oui
à la voilà par exemple ça fait partie
des choses dont je parlais tout à
l'heure où je suis heureux de ne pas les
avoir relayé on parlait tout à l'heure
de pression parce que j'ai eu des
pressions en fait que je vous dis ah là
là la pression la plus forte c'est celle
de parfois de ce côté tout le monde
vocifère tous nous on en voit la vidéo
avait plein de certitudes et c est de
résister de résister à ceux à ceux à ce
moment c'est difficile
évidemment que pour plein de raisons
tactiques
ces jeux jamais de la vie en balance des
grenades lacrymogènes par hélicoptère ou
par drones enfin je veux dire çà çà çà
çà çà n'a pas deux voilà ça n'a aucun
sens tactique je fais un clin d'oeil
puisque l'on me donne un café voilà
c'est pas bien sûr
voilà merci julie andrieu qui est
documentaliste à brut qui vient de
ramener ce p'tit kawa ce café à 20 ans
parce que la jarre est bonne parce que
moi je suis là je suis je suis mort donc
oui dans cette histoire de deux
d'hélicoptères je veux dire il faut
faire il faut faire très très attention
à l'interprétation des images à
l'interprétation du son
parce que sinon sinon on est sur du
sable
après il ya plus il ya plus rien qui
tiens voilà il faut faire attention à ça
qu'elle quelconque faible revenu en tant
que joueur ça dépasse vous êtes un peu
le cas de ceux dont on parle mais
justement avec ce flux de l'image
extrêmement important quels conseils on
pourrait donner à ceux qui nous
regardent
voilà quand vous avez un flux de vidéo
extrêmement important pour essayer de
tentes eefje une vidéo sans non plus que
ça prend aux oreilles les heures mais
éviter de tomber dans des pièges de
d'image qui ne seraient peut-être même
pas en france ou qui ne serait pas de
cette de la casse alors apparaître la
légende a d'abord d'abord il faut quand
même saluer le fait que et ça fait
partie évidemment de voilà une manière
très singulière de ce mouvement c'est à
dire qu'il faut saluer le fait que
beaucoup de gens filment beaucoup de
gens photographie et le fondant un dans
une démarche qui est pas pas uniquement
festive il ya ceux qui filment parce que
ben voilà parce que ça fait ça ça fait
du bien de se retrouver sur les ronds
points ça fait du bien d'être en
manifestation c'est un moment de deux
communes de communion et où on est on le
film mais il ya aussi des gens qui filme
le travail de la police
qui filme les blessés c'était un bon moi
j'ai pu et je dirai juste tout ce film
et tout se montre du moment que c'est
contextualiser du moment qu'on sait
qu'ils filment à quel endroit comment
éventuellement dans quel but et c'est là
la facilité du retweet la facilité du
partage la faim fait que on peut être
amené effectivement a finalement à
propager des fausses nouvelles mais
pardon pour l'instant si les gens
n'avaient pas filmer n'avait pas
photographiées et si on n'avait pas été
quelques-uns a recensé à compiler on ne
sort rien de ces victimes de ces gens
mutilés de ces gens voilà donc
ça vaut le coup de fil mais ils savent
au coût de photographier leur pareil
pour la question qui doit être posée
bien évidemment on peut filmer un
policier au travail évidemment quel que
soit son titre journalistes passent bien
sûr d'annoncer now cas de non ça c'est
pas voilà journalistes ça vous donne pas
tellement plus de droits en réalité là
ça me donne un endroit où nous dépensons
le terrain s'avère vrai parfois de
passer devant derrière un barrage de
police ou concerne ici en cercle les
manifestants pouvoir certaines sortir
avant le et même si c'est pas toujours
le cas avec des fois que l'on n'a pas
cette liberté bien sûr et on explique
dans l'elite parce que 5 des fois on est
bloqué les gens demandant vous à
l'arrière on ne peut pas passer ou même
des fois pour des raisons de sécurité
c'est pas forcément si le bon moment
voilà pour franchir en danse non ce que
ce que je veux dire c'est qui est
évidemment le frisson du live le fait
qu' on peut et la facilité du partage çà
çà çà çà peut autoriser certains pas au
tout quand j'ai autorisé je veux dire ça
ça ça peut faire en sorte qu'ils aient
des ça peut faciliter des dérapages
voilà donc faut faire gaffe certains
gardent le doute quand même par rapport
à ces images mais c'est ce soir on est
justement sur une question qui reste
intéressante sur ces images justement de
tirs de gaz lacrymogène supposé depuis
un hélicoptère où on est a expliqué que
ce n'était pas une réalité break mais
expliquer à ceux qui nous regardent
comment se fait-il que ces gaz
lacrymogènes arrive d'en haut
servat alors comment elles sont tirées
les jets de lacrymogène pour ceux de
tanger machine qu'il ya des tireurs
puisque c'est s'aider lanceur zack
limoges nc lancé s'est lancée par des
lanceurs de type cougar et autres donc
j'imagine que il ya des tireurs de gaz
lacrymogène postés en hauteur sinon il
n'y a pas d'autre explication c'est pas
automatique
voilà élevé aussi que ce soit serré en
cloche ces tirs en cloche ouais c'est à
retirer les commentaires on peut pas
tirer à bout d'un an on peut pas viser
voilà ça ne peut pas viser c'est qu'avec
ce projet doit être retiré en hauteur
normalement oui c'est tiré en hauteur et
puis en fait ensuite ça a explosé puis
si vous voulez vous avez vous avez
différentes capsules qui se dispersent
et cessons ces capsules qui envoie ce
gaz irritant qui empêchent de respirer
qui fait mal qui fait mal aux yeux
cette question justement non mais bon je
comprends que des gens se posent la
question du gaz lacrymogènes mais en
fait d'en haut mais en fait elle est
plus simple que ça la question c'est
est-ce que tirer dix mille grenade
lacrymogène en un week end c'est
acceptable moi j'ai des commandants de
crs qui me disent quand on en est là
c'est qu'il ya faillite c'est à dire que
c'est beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup trop
c'est ça que je veux dire c'est pas la
peine d'aller chercher des hélicoptères
pour questionner les la stratégie qui
est à l'oeuvre
voilà c est ce qu on a injustement on
parle de ces chiffres qui sont toujours
impressionnants après chaque week-end
quand on fait la comptabilisation du
nombre de tirs de flashball de deux
cartouches de deux cartouches de gaz
lacrymogène alors pour le canon en
hausse est de lomé
quel coup finalement ça représentait ce
qu'on a des chiffres aujourd'hui qui
permet de mettre en perspective ce qui a
été utilisé depuis le début du mouvement
c'est encore un peu tôt de belles
questions
je pense à doit pas être très compliqué
à faire il faut faire une petite règle
voilà on connaît à peu près de prix
d'une d'une grenade et logiquement on
devrait savoir le nombre de grenade
tirée donc il suffirait de multiplier il
est clair et il est clair que là il ya
déjà il ya beaucoup de dépenses on a vu
aussi ça a été là aussi révélé par le
canard enchaîné et
et très documentée par un site qui
s'appelle le reflet reflet points point
info il ya eu des commandes au moment de
la trêve de noël ait eu des commandes du
ministère de l'intérieur
de nouvelles armes notamment des six
coups des fusils qui peuvent qu'y resig
cartouches de grenade ou si l bd dont on
a vu certains certains des armes déjà à
l'oeuvre à nantes samedi dernier est
donc là on a le prix à l bd je crois ça
coûte 1700 francs suisses puisque c'est
une fabrication suisse donc ça doit être
à peu près 1200 euros le l'engin hier
soir c'est difficile demain sont obligés
depuis le début c'est des dizaines de
millions d'euros et centaines de
millions d'euros ce serait cesser dû
redonner un chiffre exact parce qu'il
est encore très tôt mais oui oui c'est
vous vieillissez en dizaines des
centaines de millions à je sais pas non
non je dis non je sais pas après si vous
voulez un sport l'ensemble c'est à dire
autant la mobilisation des
fonctionnaires de police sur le terrain
oui que non c'est resté très élevé mais
ça me semble être une question un peu
secondaire si on désire enfin je veux
dire que c'est pas c'est pas sur cet
argent là que les choses vont se décider
est ce que ça coûte trop cher ou pas
assez cher c'est pas ça je veux dire que
la france est un pays extrêmement riche
et qui fait des dépenses considérables
par exemple en termes de dar médard
maman ça reste quand même le poste
numéro un c'est pas là dessus je veux
dire c'est pour le budget de l'état
c'est à dire le budget des français
c'est heureux ça sera dérisoire je ne
dirais pas à mon avis c'est pas une
question ni politique ni stratégique
beaucoup de questions et commentaires
par rapport au gaz lacrymogène
oui par rapport à la composition alors
indépendant détaillent la composition
est ce que aujourd'hui on sait si un
risque sur la sur la santé à long terme
le fait de respirer les gaz lacrymogènes
de façon j'ai oublié il ya alors ça je
crois que c'est très important
d'ailleurs d'en parler il ya tout ce
qu'on appelle les les les street midi
coup les secouristes volontaires qu'on
voit à l'oeuvre chan s'est rendu
régulièrement qu'on a même inventé
relevé dans la manif du ce qui m'enerve
en direct le legs du 5 janvier on était
à leur rencontre et nous expliquer leur
travail voilà donc ce sont des gens qui
viennent au secours
en théorie aussi bien des policiers que
des manifestants il se trouve que les
policiers ils ont ils ont des médecins a
vécu aux fins des infirmiers puisse
exactement donc ils sont pas tellement
besoin d'être et munich donc c'est vrai
que les cette musique vous viennent donc
médecins de rue c'est ce que ça signifie
donc c'est des gens qui viennent à
l'aide auprès des victimes et qu'on voit
tout de suite surgir dès que dès qu'il
ya des des quais des problèmes
selon quelques postes que j'ai pu lire
de certains collectif de street midi
coup il ya des dangers pour la santé qui
sont qui sont qu'ils sont sérieux qui
sont qu'ils sont importants
tout ça est tout à fait documenté c'est
à dire que c'est sur le long terme dans
dix quinze ans pour avoir des relations
non non c'est vraiment quelque chose de
dans mon souvenir cécilia problème c'est
instantané à face instantanée n'y a pas
de risque non non non non
oui il ya des choses bien sûr d'elle en
15 ans les personnes non maintenant sa
mort on me le dire parce que ça crée
beaucoup qui pose cette question sur
d'accord non maintenant ça non mais je
comprends que les gens posent cette
question parce que malgré tout le gaz
lacrymogène qui a été inventé il ya très
très très longtemps
c'est dans la famille des armes
chimiques
c'est chimique à gaz lacrymogènes donc
oui il ya des séquelles mais là encore
il faudrait il faudrait aller voir les
les étudiant e il ya eu des études
sanitaires qui ont été tués a été mené
est là aussi le l'abondance dans l'
usage des gaz lacrymogènes hymne et
interroge cette question qui se pose
dans les commentaires mais on pourra y
répondre en ce sens parce que certains
font référence aux à notre direct de
samedi dernier où les personnes qui nous
ont suivi ont vu ces images d'une
personne qui est touché à côté de la
place de l'étoile par le canon à eau
oui qui s'écroule au sol oui plusieurs
personnes vont à assat en convoi pour
acheter cette personne qui au sol et qui
bouge pas à ce moment là donc pressé de
l'extraire et qui du coup ces personnes
se retrouvent à leur tour visé par le
canon à eau et par par des voleurs
explosive alors en leur direction
et ces images elles font partie de ce
que vous avez signalé également en place
beauvau pour examen métaux on lit
absolument
là là c'est le bon sens quoi c'est à
dire que là il ya un truc qui est assez
qui est assez dégueulasse il ya
quelqu'un qui est au sol je tiens à dire
que dans le mode d'emploi par exemple
des bides et je crois même que le dgpn
direct a géré la police nationale a
rappelé 1
si un policier fait usage de cette arme
là il doit s'enquérir de l'état de santé
de la personne dans une charge crs s'il
ya un tir de l bd ou de flashball
le mode d'emploi ce qu'on appelle la
doctrine d'emploi la règle d'engagement
fait que normalement compagnies de crs
ou de gendarmes mobiles doit s'inquiéter
de l'état de santé de la personne qui
est au sol et bien là il ya une personne
au sol à cause du canon à eau
il ya des gens qui viennent à sa son
secours pour la relever pour
éventuellement d'exfiltrer l'amener à
des médecins l'a mené à des infirmiers
district pudique et là ces gens là à
leur tour reçoivent canons à eau c'est
pas à l'honneur de la police voilà c'est
tout c'est pas l'honneur de la police
c'est pas gravissime mais c'est pas
l'honneur de la police est de mon point
de vue ça nous ça ne ça ne colle pas
avec la déontologie de la police
si vraiment des gens qui nous écoutent
sont intéressés par par ces questions là
vous tapez dans google
défenseur des droits rapport sur la
déontologie du maintien de l'ordre
et vous avez trente pages absolument
passionnante qui font autorité sur
l'emploi des armes
comment ils doivent être utilisés par
qui et c'est vous avez quantité c'est
donc le défenseur des droits qui a
promis son rapport au parlement dans
lequel il recommande plusieurs choses
dont ce qu'on répète depuis depuis tout
à l'heure
l'arrêt immédiat de l'usagé de la bd des
flashball
mais également l'arrêt des nas j'ai été
très surpris en lisant ce rapport que
les nas quand on as donc le défenseur
des droits appelle ça le lan call
l'engagement bon n'appelle pas ça une
das les manifestants face à une menace
mais enfin manifestement côté policier
on appellerait ça engagement et bien
d'après le défenseur des droits ça ne
répond à aucune règle écrite quelque
part donc ces nas on peut s'interroger
sur leur légalité on va dire donc
vraiment je je conseille aux gens qui
sont intéressés par ces questions là
d'aller lire ce rapport parce que ce
rapport il est très clair il est très
simple et directe à et il est de
décembre 2017 c'est à dire il est dire
quasiment en tout cas il ya eu une année
pour que les parlementaires sont
saisissent et se disent qu'est ce qu'on
fait eh bien les parlementaires n'ont
rien fait
le politique n'a pas tenu compte de ces
recommandations
je pense que c'est une occasion tous ces
signalements toutes ces bavures
toutes ces mutilations sont l'occasion
de dire et et qu'est ce qu'on fait ce
rapport est ce qu on peut débattre alors
que le gouvernement puisse pas débattre
entre deux actes et ils disent c'est pas
le moment de changer
on change pas
de cheval au milieu du gué bon ok mais
est ce que cette question va être posée
la déontologie du maintien de l'ordre
parce que se dire si ce fonds auquel on
assiste maintenant depuis qu'ils aient
pas à nouveau encaissé il faudrait pas
que le mouvement gilet jaune pense qu'il
est le premier à être victimes d'une
répression c'est pas vrai ce que le
mouvement des gilets jaunes reçoit
aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on a vu à la zad
de notre dame des landes
vous y étiez une forme de militarisation
c'est ce qu'on a vu à l'aloha travail et
et c'est ce qu'on voit depuis 15-20 ans
dans les cités mais on est bien qu'avant
c'est ce que c'est vrai alors que
pourraient prendre les maisons vous
donne des manifestations au travail the
hills alors il ya un jeune journaliste
ne tombez pas dans les travers des vieux
journaliste est ce que c'est nouveau
mais c'est dans le canton de verser 1
par exemple
ouais parce que les gendarmes aient
choisi parce que c'est mieux maintenant
est-ce que c'est pire qu'avant aisance
et comme une question qui peut se poser
oui oui bien sûr mais la question de la
nouveauté et pas en fait elle est un peu
naïf
non ce qui est notable aujourd'hui c'est
la densité c'est la répétition
c'est à dire c'est toutes les semaines
c'est toutes les semaines qu'on en voit
des policiers non formés au maintien de
l'ordre faire du maintien de l'ordre
et c'est toutes les semaines qu'on voit
des blessés qu'on constate des blessés
et certains graves des mutilés ça si
vous voulez depuis au moins 68 ça
n'était pas arrivé
ça c'est très clair dont 15 ans ils sont
mais en même temps aucun mouvement comme
les gilets jaunes avaient
exister +68 là le seul moment si vous
voulez on pourrait dire que l'état que
le maintien de l'ordre étaient vraiment
une préoccupation centrale c'est les
émeutes de 2005
on a les émeutes de 2005 et on a le lait
gilet jaune
voilà entre les deux et avant il n'y a
pas eu cet état aussi aussi dur aussi
dense entre les autres l'état d'un côté
et puis et puis la rue on a remercié
tous ceux qui qui revient cela
effectivement je regarde les les
commentaires vous êtes très nombreux
encore rester quelques minutes avant de
conclure cela avec les dernières
questions de ce direct on vous remercie
en tout cas d'être d'être avec nous
alors le pendant que vous cherchez de
questions à moi vous l'ayez tout de
suite je voudrais juste
passer un petit message aux gens qui ont
la gentillesse de prendre le temps de
contacter pour me faire part de
d'agissements qui leur semble illégitime
des forces de l'ordre il faut un tout
petit peu de méthode parce que sinon je
croule donc la meilleure des façons
c'est de m'envoyer un email via mon site
ou un dm via twitter avec un maximum
d'informations et de vie répond afin que
les questions de base c'est twitter à la
fin à limoges où quand comment
parce que voyez juste une page facebook
ça me demandent ensuite beaucoup de
temps donc voilà si si vous avez envie
que ce travail démocratique et citoyen
soit fait il ya des gens comme j'ai dit
tout à l'heure qui m'aident qui
justement essayer de débroussailler
voilà si vous me signaler des choses
idéalement c'est par e-mail prenez le
temps de m'envoyer un email avec le plus
possible de 2 d'où ça vient
qu'est ce que vous avez vu ici vous avez
des photos si vous avez des vidéos etc
le temps vous y trouvez une question
somme ont bien vu que même de questions
sur lens en hausse là mais également par
rapport au traitement médiatique de ces
violences policières oui certains
faisaient les comparaisons de quand on
parle des violences dans les
manifestations mais refuse réponse
policière on a peu entendu parler
comment vous l'expliquez ce que vous
avez une analyse sur ce point là alors
[Musique]
je voulais vie au tout début quand j'ai
commencé à compiler les photos les
vidéos de violences policières dans le
cadre du mouvement gilet jaune un des
ressorts c'était que je ne comprenais
pas que ces images qui circulent et qui
font des millions de vues je veux dire
qu'il ya un moment on peut pas dire que
c'est confidentiel pas du tout
ces images ne sortait pas à des réseaux
sociaux servent n'arrivait pas dans des
espaces de discussions de débats qui
sont qui sont des médias qui sont les
les émission d'info les chaînes d'info
etc
alors là je dois dire des choses parce
que j'ai rencontré beaucoup de reporter
qui sont les premiers désolés de ne pas
avoir pu faire de reportage parce que
les rédactions en chef n'y croyais pas
tellement ne voyait pas trop l'intérêt
et c'est rageant
moi je vais être très clair je pense que
le
les médias qui sont extrêmement
nécessaire le son quand ils sont des
contre-pouvoirs et si les médias ne sont
pas des contre-pouvoirs 11 à mes yeux
ils perdent un petit peu de leur intérêt
quoi et il n'y a rien de plus dur
médiatiquement que de travailler une
bavure policière parce que vous attaquer
frontalement de l'état vous attaquez
quasiment la raison d'état vous attaquez
la violence légitime qui est que le
monopole pardon le monopole de la
violence légitime qui a accordé à l'état
donc c'est extrêmement difficile
alors ça s'est réveillée depuis quelques
jours depuis quelques jours le débat il
est sur la place publique et au journal
de 20 heures de tf1 de france 2 il dit
sur bfm essayer les choses sont partis
et on j'espère que samedi soir il n'y
aura pas que les violences des
manifestants à l'encontre des policiers
qui aura aussi le pendant et qui aura
surtout des discussions des réflexions
politiques sur pourquoi on est là
pourquoi ça se passe comme ça donc
clairement je dirais que le silence
médiatique globalement parce
qu'évidemment il ya des contre-exemples
pour moi il ajouté de la violence à la
violence
voilà il y avait quelque chose
d'extrêmement violent notamment pour les
victimes d'être victime dans le le déni
médiatique se délient médiatique c'est
fini ça y est vous évoquez justement là
bas je j'ai lu pas mal de vos
interventions médiatiques de ces
derniers jours sur le fait que pour
certains jouets c'est compliqué de les
dénoncer parce que leurs propres
ressources pour rêver des informations
et des services police justice si vous
voulez bah oui très clairement
la police est quand même un monde
demande a le secret c'est donc très
difficile d'avoir des informations et
donc quand vous avez des informations de
seconde
vous avez dit ce qu'on appelle des
sources ces sources
si vous passez votre temps à les
interroger sur ce qui s'est mal passé
bah vous aurez plus tellement
d'informations là c'est aussi clair que
ça donc il ya ce point de vue que c'est
c'est ça la peur de vexer la peur de pas
avoir de deux d'information d'être
d'être d'être d'être coupés alors il ya
il ya quelque chose qui tient la rend
plus les policiers sont souvent soumis
au devoir de réserve tant qu'ils ne
peuvent pas parler donc qui parlent sont
les syndicats et les syndicats s'ils
voulaient cétacés s'entendait dans d une
position qui est extrêmement compliqué
parce qu'ils sont à la fois courroie de
transmission du ministère de l'intérieur
porte parole de leurs adhérents sources
des journalistes est donc très compliqué
pour pour les syndicats d'apparaître
publiquement avec une parole qui soit je
dirais totalement entière voilà donc si
vous voulez travailler sur la police est
très compliqué quand on est quand on est
journaliste
mais je regrette qui est
si peu de courage journalistique en
matière de dans cette matière voilà il
ya quelques journalistes évidemment un
maigrot globalement par rapport à ce que
je disais tout à l'heure on n'est pas
dans le contre-pouvoir voilà si on
regarde les journaux dits à 10 15 ans il
y avait beaucoup plus de débats y avait
une couverture médiatique beaucoup plus
forte sur les zones la part d'ombré de
la police beaucoup plus aujourd'hui vous
l'avez encore un vous l'avez encore avec
le monde avec parfois libération avec le
canard enchaîné avec mediapart
vous avez quand même des rédactions mais
une chaîne d'info en continu je vous
donne un exemple tout bête si elle veut
être sur tous les coups si elle veut
être sur l'interpellation du dernier
voyou en cavale et bien elle a intérêt à
être bien avec ces sources
voilà c'est pas c'est pas du
machiavélisme que c'est pas si c'est
quasiment naturelle je veux dire que
c'est de la relation de travail comme
comme tous les gens qui nous regardent
ont des relations de travail et la
relation de travail fait que vous n'avez
pas forcément une liberté de manoeuvre
aussi grande mais là je salue le fait
que les reporters ont réussi depuis
quelques jours à convaincre les
rédactions en chef que il y avait débat
à mener cette question qui se pose aussi
part belle au ministère de l'intérieur
ministre l'intérieur
oui bah voilà nous mêmes on l'a
rencontré la semaine dernière à
christophe castaner on a l'impression
que c'est impossible d'avoir une
condamnation de la part d'un ministre de
l'intérieur de violences policières
est-ce que c'est politique c'est de la
communication que l'on commet elle un
clip très sain alors
je vous en veux
rémy vous soyez du mans menez vous
auriez du monde mais parce que à votre
corps défendant
le ministre a fait la une opération de
communication
vous l'avez poser des questions il a
répondu mise intérieur principalement
c'est ainsi quelqu'un qui fait de la
ccta directeurs de ressources humaines
il a presque 200 mille personnes à gérer
policiers de gendarmes etc ça veut dire
que si commun de ces violences
policières il se met en froid s'est
abattue lycée sacré frondeurs ça ferait
quoi imaginer voilà christophe castaner
qui y voit là je condamne fermement
certains agissements certaines
utilisations non légale de certains
armements derrière ça on a sacré nous on
a des ministres ago i say gilet jaune
on ad on a des ministres de l'intérieur
comme pierre joxe par exemple qu'ils
n'avaient pas peur d'aller au contact
qui n'avait pas peur d'eux
de dénoncer les agissements illégitime
illégaux des policiers on peut
comprendre qu'il soit gêné aux
entournures on peut comprendre qu'il
verrait qu'il vous réponde comme il l'a
fait avec les circonvolutions etc
en revanche on peut pas admettre c'est
ce que moi j'appelle des mensonges
d'état c'est à dire nous dire deux fois
une fois à carcassonne une fois à
l'assemblée hier qu' il ne connais pas
un seul policier qui a agressé un gilet
jaune
bon là je suis désolé mais je veux dire
soit c'est de la compétence soit c'est
du mensonge dans les deux cas si une
faute
donc je trouve que christophe castaner
va pas quand même très très loin dans le
temps dans le déni et c'est pas la
hauteur d'un homme d'état c'est pas la
hauteur de quelqu'un qui est le numéro 2
puisque mis les intérieurs ces numéros
devient président de la république enfin
non muselé numéro trois essais mais
après mais on a plus de chances de
devenir président de la république en
ayant été mise un tailleur que premier
ministre pour garder ce crime république
c'est comme ça c'est de la poudre aux
moins devenu candidat c'est un boss et
oui c'est un poste absolument clé est là
ça va ça va amener vers quoi quand on
entend certains qui disent la démission
de christophe castaner est ce que c'est
cette situation quand il y aura le bilan
à la fin de ces mobilisations
voilà on a déjà un chiffre de blessés
importants alors on espère qu'ils ont
pas s'aggraver mais il ya un risque
quand même si vous voulez christophe
castaner je pense que
sur ce mail de son point de vue et il
arrive à beauvau est il à ce mouvement
qui lui tombe dessus
il est pas tout à fait responsable dé la
doctrine depuis une quinzaine vingtaine
d'années du maintien de l'ordre
par contre ils l'appliquent allègrement
bon en nyon les les débordements donc
ils l'assument
voilà s'il assume il devra l'assumer
publiquement si tenté que si tenté que
d'à côté le citoyen lui pose la question
où le politique où les représentants où
les médias sercan fait cc3c ces trois
entités qui peuvent porter le débat le
politique on l'a vu sais-tu sur le
rapport du défenseur des droits
le médiatique a eu du mal à embrayer sur
les violences policières
donc effectivement ça va être un débat
qui sera portée qui devrait être porté
par les citoyens voilà moi je me
prononce pas sur des missions ou pas de
christophe casper s'est pas séparé de
prolongation oui et puis et puis surtout
moi je veux surtout pas faire de
politique fiction je vous dire je vois
là je
je vois là je pense que j'ai répondu il
ya cette idée qu'il hérite d'une
doctrine dont il n'est donc pas
responsable mais qu'ils l'appliquent
énormément et qu'ils en assument les
pires conséquences
donc à un moment donné assumer ça veut
ça doit aller au bout voilà c'est pas
uniquement justement des interviews
rapide
non c'est il ya de toute façon la france
sauf est en train de vivre un examen de
conscience et qui va avec le mouvement
gilet jaune et cet examen de conscience
il va se faire aussi abandonné sur le
rôle de la police sur sa doctrine dans
l'enseignement à prendre après
évidemment évidemment évidemment
merci en tout cas david dufresne je vais
puiser j'ai des années en tout cas vous
avez été on a été jusqu'au bout et je
pense que c'est voilà on a fait
exactement 1h55 de là et je vous en
remercie vraiment au fond du coeur parce
que pour ceux qui nous regardent tout
simplement parce que c'est un sujet
qu'on vous l'a évoquée parmi d'autres
on voulait avoir votre avis parce que
c'est vrai que bah vous suivez le
mouvement des jeunes depuis début vous
avez écrit à plusieurs reprises là tu
sais pas c'est pas arrivé avec le
mouvement les jambes que c'était
intéressant d'avoir votre point de vue
et pendant ces deux heures de live
j'espère que tous ceux qui nous
regardent ou qui nous regardent et que
ce soit quelques secondes quelques
minutes ou même pendant presque deux
heures auront pu mieux comprendre
certaines de ces questions certains
éclairages aussi qu'on a pu donner malek
vous david dufresne sur des situations
également à l'étranger on a beaucoup
parlé de ce qui se passe en allemagne en
angleterre et c'était intéressant aussi
cette comparaison de deux techniques
entre guillemets de maintien de l'ordre
entre ce qui se passe en france et à
l'étranger
on parlait aussi du sens de ce que ce
que vous faites un saut les réseaux
sociaux est peut-être le le répéter deux
dernières fois pour ceux qui l'on
regarde actuellement sur votre bon
buteur avec ce halo place beauvau où
vous recensez donc
le début du mouvement des gilet jaune
des cas de violences policières et vous
vous interpeller directement sur les
réseaux sociaux
voilà le ministère le ministre de
l'intérieur voilà merci à vous on espère
encaisser car vous avoir éclairé sur 7
sur cette actualité à savoir et si vous
étiez nombreux à poser cette question
que cela y va comme tous nos directs
seront disponibles en archivage et en
intégralité à la fin de ce live serre
que dès que moi je vais appeler son
bouton terminé vous pourrez retrouver
l'ensemble de cette interview donc ceux
qui sont arrivés en cours de live et
bien vous pourrez retrouver le replay de
soleil dans quelques instants
je voulais vous remercier sincèrement
vous remercier pour vos commentaires
vous êtes très nombreux encore à
commenter et à nous remercier pour ce
direct ben nous on vous remercie d'avoir
été là puis on vous remercie encore une
fois david dufresne pour le temps que
vous nous avez je n'en ai pas accordé
je vais jamais jusque là il ya une
raison un et elle raison c'est que ce
mouvement est intimement liée aux
réseaux sociaux
mon travail actuel est intimement liée
aux réseaux sociaux
et quand vous m'avez appelé évidemment
j'ai dit oui tout de suite parce que
parce que d'une certaine manière c'est
une façon de boucler la boucle
voilà équivoque évidemment cette parole
qui se libère
si elle reste au responsable c'est à
dire que si on part pas dans les dents
les dans les dents les intox dans les
diffamations dans les insultes dans les
injures raciales misogynie l'homophobie
etc
cette parole qui se libère elle est
extraordinaire voilà et puis là donc
c'était une façon de vous remercier
et là c'est très bien on va merci merci
à vous et puis voilà on voulait sont sur
ces images et puis on se retrouve là
vers très vite pour de nouvelles images
en direct au coeur de l'actualité au
plus tard samedi on sera là pour couvrir
à l'acte 10 des gilets jaunes dans la
dans la capitale comme on a pu faire
durant les précédents week-ends donc on
se retrouvera on dirait que c'était une
usine pour rue depuis la rédaction avec
david dufresne en live à voir ou revoir
en intégralité dès maintenant prenez
soin de vous bonne soirée et à très très
vite sur brut et merci encore à vous
merci